merry christmas
merry christmas a little late this is
the promised the destin
christmas special that we plant we were
piping up last year talking about all
this prep we've been doing
you know that it was gonna be such a
banger well it's here
uh you know late
but we put in so much prep we said dang
we're doing the christmas special that's
just what it is
so welcome everybody merry christmas
we have so many surprises
presents
sketches goofs gaffs at galore
ela fit check you're looking like
a gajillion dollars look at this thank
you what the heck bro honestly you guys
see my shoes though you want to put them
on the table let's see yeah you look got
some wild new shoes i think we need to
acknowledge
with tap
here you need food on the table
yeah
look at this white
straight like uh dang like uh old
people's furniture tassels on her shoe
what's that all right thank you
it's fine
vin diesel approved that was my exercise
for the whole day yeah i got you
that ain't easy
so fit check real quick i wanted to
thank um well our sponsors today are
hello freshman mobile and also sitting
next to us is the ceo
of teddyfresh.com
let's show it off this is a beautiful
drop really excited about it
this hoodie i'm wearing the sherpa
floral is fresh
the beanie you all been asking about is
on the website this jacket is on the
website the shirt too right
hey b's wearing some fresh teddy fresh
you want to show it off
corduroy shirt what's up what's up
what's up what's up what's up what's up
what's up
so let's take a look here
we've got the jacket this is what i'm
wearing is what ela's wearing this is
what abs wearing
matching pants
the thrill is gone tea a badass teddy
bear jacquarded sweater
all kinds of stuff honestly go to
teddypress.com
here's the beanie oh no this one's sold
out that was fast
but there's all these other really cool
um
variants
uh hair clips
you know jewelry
socks you know
anyway teddyfresh.com check it out thank
you all right
so um
oh there's a new bts a b you wanted to
plug that for members you just walked
away but yeah yeah it will be a new bts
for members
after the show after the show thank you
for the show nice
too many spoilers for today's episode
but basically we you know got all this
chicken in preparation yeah what's going
on here well so um
jollibee
is the chicken that uh nicocado
avocado recommended he wanted us to eat
and
i wanted to do it with him but
he decided not to come
to the interview
that we
got the first class ticket for and the
hotel for were we able to get a refund
any of that stuff dan at the hotel yes
but um we'll talk about the flight
afterwards yeah i assume not
you can't cancel a first question yeah
first class ticket like
well you can if you pay like almost
double the price for a refundable ticket
which i did not do oh well yeah i don't
blame you for that who's like whatever
yeah so anyway um
yeah so we i have all this chicken i was
thinking i'd eat it with you you know
with me yeah
no
no i was actually just gonna say that
this smells making me sick really it's
strong
so
i was thinking i'm going to walk off for
a minute you're going to leave yeah wow
it is strong either you have strong you
didn't give me a heads up versions when
you're pregnant yeah
okay
you don't want to have any chicken with
me
no bruh
none no you don't even try it this nick
this is nick's favorite chicken jolly no
i thought it was jubilee it's a jubilee
with jollibee
no
okay when am i gonna sit here and eat
this chicken by myself
uh yeah and you've got like 30 000
people
in spirit all right eating with you
bye
wow brutal
[Music]
to feast
or not to feast
i was supposed to sit here today
with my water-weighted friend
nicotto
alas
the mukbang is no more
i have 20 pounds of fried chicken
[Music]
50 pounds
of cheese melted mashed potatoes
we were gonna block some arteries today
and now
i am one man surrounded by a sea of
fried chicken
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's so good but it will be so much
better with nick
nicol
why have you done this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
who am i gonna share this right chicken
with
if only there was somebody
anybody to share this fried chicken with
[Music]
huh
[Applause]
[Music]
want to say fried chicken friday
even though it's friday it's supposed to
be fried chicken wednesday but i'll say
fried chicken friday baby
[Applause]
this is the perfect guy to share fried
chicken have grab a piece come on you
saved the day i love i love jollibee
jollibee is one of my favorite fried
chickens oh my god
kfc
[Music]
you saved my life oh you're welcome
gabe is here white clock gabe it's
friday i know fried chicken is on a win
is a wednesday food but it's okay we're
making the exception here
any day
fried chicken saturday
fried chicken fried is good
wow thank you so much for being here
sure
who needs nick avocado when you got
white clock game yeah
so this is one of your favorite fried
chickens huh oh yeah
which other which other fried chickens
are like top test here
to me personally kfc they have seizure
faith my favorite and then jelly beans
yeah
hmm kfc
the original not the extra crispy huh
that's the crispy's [ __ ] it's all
right but i like the original the best
right
that makes sense i mean it's the
original formulation
what can beat
that so how much do you eat a little
fried chicken like i have some bristle
left and some skin here do you eat all
of it i eat all of it
especially the skin the skin's my
favorite really
i think beats the skin
i love skin chicken skin the best
would you ever consider eating just the
skin
i used to as a kid but when i start
enjoying chicken more you know i start
going into the meal just for you
for christmas oh yeah just the skin baby
merry christmas very late and early
early early christmas early 22. that's
true it's kind of more of an early
christmas than like christmas
hell yeah bro
well
i'm so glad you're here
we're doing a gift exchange oh yeah
do you know who nick avocado is
like avocado the fruit
yeah i mean well
i mean no he's not a fruit he's a man is
that better than avocado he flaked on me
he was supposed to be eating fried
chicken
and he flaked oh
that's not yet
as flaky as the skin on this chicken
itself
flakier in fact look oh yeah
so i got you a gift here let me see how
you crush that and then when you're done
i got a gift over here i want you to
open
um
how would you actually dude
that birthday party was off the rails it
is
do you go to strip clubs regularly
well
ever so up not not so up maybe once in a
while once in a while yeah
just want to get do you always get a lap
dance when you go
i got a free lockdown so if everybody
noticed me
oh [ __ ]
all right i freely let down is it true
that dude i've never been to a strip
club but i've heard that dudes just
straight up finishing their pants is
that true
i don't know i haven't seen it but i
hear it's true here's true also
you guys heard that dudes just go there
and finish in their pants i was like
whoa that's gnarly
oh just walking around with soggy pants
oh they must have peed in it
okay well you see that tall present
right there yeah that one there yeah go
ahead and open that we have a camera
there for you oh sure
we got you something special for
christmas
you guys got that on
[Applause]
show it to the camera
turn it on we got you the original
white claw
light sign
this is the real deal
we had to get
we had to get this directly from the
white claw people we had to bend their
you know arms
lots of negotiating lots of haggling
behind
they ain't no loss with the claws
especially the white claw light baby
this is a good omen for you i think this
means a good year ahead for you yeah
hopefully a great 2022 baby
so i understand you got me a present as
well sure
i get a napkin uh
[Music]
mary late
and early early early early christmas
either i love that i love the early
early early christmas okay january you
want to know something interesting about
me what is it
my birthday is on june 25th okay that's
exactly
like mid-year and
six months exactly from christmas
so it's like halfway there it's a half
christmas can i ask you something
because jesus was born on christmas day
right
so when would the antichrist be born
theoretically like the opposite of
christ when would he be born
probably probably june i guess june 25th
to be back that's my birthday
am i the antichrist
that would be the antichrist birthday i
need a napkin sam before i open this my
hands are all greasy from this jolly bee
jolly so are you cut so yeah
what's going on i heard you you got
shadow banned on tick tock
well the problem is you know every time
every time i get a
a flag or community violation they
always shadow ban me
and then when i get shadow man my views
go down
so what happens is my views
it goes up to 10 000 and it kind of
tapped on it and wait what do you get
violations for
what do you do like
hate speech hates me hate speech um
what else
nudity
all kinds of stuff it's it's like
it's like they're like picking on me and
stuff wait what kind of hate speech are
you are you saying
hate speech is like
like come on you know like
i'm on your dumb [ __ ] or whatever oh
this is the key word
the c word do you say this don't say
that no i don't see that it's like you
dumb [ __ ] or you
call me stupid right hey he's stupid and
then they they flag it for hate speech
they all kick it on me
but by the way does he say the c word
because that is considered hate speech
no that's not his
algorithm
got it
got it
he's saying that they wouldn't always
win the appeal but because of the
excessive cursing the cursing and stuff
you know even though i win the case it
still it still goes on my record like
like a community violation like a felon
your tick tock felon something like that
you know am i a criminal no you know i'm
just
my um
my i'm not meant for offense i suppose
my um my contest must have meant for
something funny you know a laughter and
stuff not hateful not hateful and stuff
not i'm not hurting people i'm just
doing it just to get a laugh or get
people's reaction
hmm that's a shame what white clock gave
on tick tock everyone we got a free
white claw game free white collar yeah
i reached like 1.2 million followers and
it went down to 1.0 it's like they wiped
200 000
followers because of my you know my
recent you know violation itself it's
not fair for me i'm doing the hard work
i'm getting the viewers i'm getting the
followers and they kind of treat me like
that that's not fair for me you know i
work hard i make a living on social
media that's my living i pay my bills i
pay my rent because of social media my
tick tocks
wow
sounds like a hard time
stressful it is you know i work hard you
know that's my that's my work that's my
job right you know my job's to make
people laugh my job's to get get a laugh
out of people you know my job's not to
offend people you know i i like i i get
a kick of people just getting a laugh
out of you know my my content and stuff
just the [ __ ] baby [ __ ] you know right
[ __ ] baby have you considered maybe
maybe we need to enter some new kind of
curse words like
right now we're to have like the [ __ ]
baby [ __ ] woo
maybe we can mix it up with like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and a [ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] yeah
getting a [ __ ] [ __ ] baby [ __ ] baby
just something fresh i think something
like that the audience oh yeah can we
think of something now that you can take
to tick-tock and then we could kind of
be like
we're we support this oh yeah you like
[ __ ] [ __ ] in a bit [ __ ] on a [ __ ] or
maybe that's that maybe might be
misogynistic how about eat [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] eat [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] it yeah that's pretty good
what about the [ __ ] my ass baby [ __ ]
my ass who's wiping [ __ ] off my ass
that's good that's good or how about
peeing my butthole baby
oh yeah just shocking the outrage
the brown piss whoa
that's pretty graphic
yeah something i'm just saying i'm
giving i'm just like it's it's just
ideas you know i but i think maybe that
would be the ticket for you guys oh yeah
no anyway let me let me see what you got
me sure okay
all right so white club game got me a
present
it's a box
let's see here
it says nike is it a shoe it's something
like that a nikkei
okay
oh these are fire
oh baby
baby [ __ ]
yo these are fire what
mary late late christmas early early
early early early christmas
2022 yo
are these a special shoe or are they
just fire ass shoes it's like fire ass
shoes or maybe special
yeah whatever you want to name it i'm
going to wear these all right i got
thick ass souls too to make my my beta
my gamma maleness uh all right yeah
less evident
thank you gabe that was very nice to you
you're welcome thanks bro
early early christmas
love you buddy thanks
these shoes are awesome you know what
let me put them on right now
let's go go first you all know about me
i don't like to lace my shoes up you
know why i don't like those high-top
shoes they're just so hard to put in oh
yeah look at that yeah
score baby
well thanks buddy it's been a great to
sit here with you
um
what do you think should we should maybe
should we decide on something for the
new like just to try
you know
which one do you think the [ __ ] [ __ ]
when you came up [ __ ] on a [ __ ] yes
that one might be perceived as
misogynistic that might get you back
into trouble oh that is true yeah i i
reeled back on that one well there was
one after that i liked pissing my ass
yeah maybe that one man
that kind of worked me in my butt
yeah my butt baby [ __ ]
and you're right try
yeah pee in my butt
yeah that's good you hit that butt hard
try that
yeah tap the pee out of my butt baby
well also you're peeing out of your butt
but also say pee in my butt in my butt
yeah try it again try to pee in my butt
i think that's got legs i think that's
the winner i think it's got legs
give it a shot i'm definitely gonna be
gonna be liking that one all right well
thank you gabe
i'm gonna honor and enjoy
like free white cloud gabe on tick tock
everyone free white clock game everybody
get out be looking out for the um
the p p in my butt okay sucks right
we'll try that one yeah give it a shot
yeah hit hard that's some new material
you just got to reinvent yourself you
know exactly just reinvent the
the wheel
we're reinventing the wheel it's going
to keep going another way
sure
here here's a fat one bro
yeah chicken skin just the skin for my
boy mary
mary very late christmas early
[Applause]
oh
yeah thanks brother yep chicken skin
baby
oh yeah [ __ ] piss in my butt
all right cool all right
thanks brother thanks gabe
take care buddy
yeah we're gonna clear off the chicken
well
wow what an honor to meet you gabe
himself what's going on here he's just
in this way
there's just a lot of chicken
oh i'm not done
no you're not done
i could no way dude i know who wants
some the doggies
they're circling
well
that was exciting oh what
what are you guys doing these guys gotta
can someone get them some chicken i know
there's gonna be a lot of leftovers
just tear it off the bone
give it to him
maybe we can even get a shot of them
devouring it
actually the real reason we got the
jollibee is for um love to try
oh yeah we're doing a segment where
he's trying all kinds of crazy american
fast foods
gotcha he tried taco bell
how was that he loved it
he did love it
um so basically there's that
actually just to touch on the nicocado
situation a bit yeah so he did cancel
there's been lots of theories and
speculation the thing
you know
that kind of put me over the top i made
a video about it on my h3 tv channel but
the thing is he put his video
is that on the podcast or on no on no
it's on the uh channel h3 tv tv because
that's the name of the podcast that we
did here right
i was thinking of changing the channel
name to ethan klein i actually like that
i love it yeah right i like that i think
it's genius it's me this is you it's me
he's inclined here he is yeah here he is
trailblazing
it's kind of i agree it is kind of
genius thank you for noticing
it's so so genius i think you should go
home and do it right away right now just
do it just rip off the business leave
[Laughter]
yeah so um the thing about nickacado
he canceled but what really kind of
rubbed me wrong was that he put
his response video his ex his
explanation behind a paywall i agree
same four dollar paywall
which we did pay for i already talked
about this but this is fair use i went
over with my attorney
we paid for it we obtained it legally
i don't really want to watch it again
but it's basically just him saying that
the following disclaimer from howard
wrote ethan i called him back
i made fun of his off
and but also
he's not getting enough views he said
from his videos about me
and he said that um
it's not worth it he just doesn't want
to come
which i guess it's fine it is fine but
a lot of people are speculating that he
never was gonna come to begin with and i
don't know if that's true or not maybe i
mean i'm gonna come based off of because
i coordinated with him to get him out
here uh yeah i would say
um without you know giving away any
private communication with him that um
that he was planning on coming i mean it
was an extensive
discussion um i think he was looking for
any reason to
be i mean he may have he may have always
been on the fence but he he was nothing
but professional behind the scenes uh
setting it all up and everything and
even when he bowed out he was very
respectful in the message that he sent
me and everything it was well what are
your thoughts about
what i viewed this as and again this is
fair use i'd clear it with my lawyer
it's funny because he's got this big
scary thing about you will be sued
please note the following that's not
fair
uh
what it's like i felt like he did this
so i couldn't
respond like he puts out all this bs
about how i'm like homophobic and yeah
and like chauvinistic against him like
you wouldn't say that about a woman
and you're making fun of my gayness yeah
and then i was like bruh
that stuff was what i didn't like
because that's like
that all of a sudden took a turn
like our council he never expressed any
of those emotions throughout all the
banter of the back and forth and well he
was making fun of us just as much as we
yeah it seems like mutual i never called
me you kept calling me out for being fat
i mean off the gate he was mean to
olivia
right but like we all thought it was
we're all joking like and didn't he
start the reaction meta too i mean he's
the one that react and i i really
thought we were just doing banter we had
like the four
meta reaction going on
i thought we would just keep doing it
but for him he's like i'm not getting
any views out of this so you know fu
that's how i saw it
after i kind of mentioned it on youtube
i don't know what i'm going to say
but okay when i
he talks for a while and uh pretty much
summarize it but the tr in truth
um
we i sent it i i was like hey i sent him
my email and i was like dude you know
some of the comments i made were maybe
you know
i took the banter
very far
like calling his
that last one yeah maybe i took it too
far i said his his paper looked like a
cow's vagina god
we knew what you said i don't know what
to say
maybe that i think that was too far
probably
that was maybe too far but my whole
rationale was like that his whole
content his whole shtick and persona
is shocking and outrageous
like we were looking at his own his uh
patreon his where we got access to this
video and the pictures in there are it's
clearly made to be outrageous and
shocking
it's very shocking i mean it's gnarly as
[ __ ] i will take your word for it yeah
dan bailed everyone else well okay i'm
not gonna talk about it
but yeah it was pretty shocking stuff
but regardless um
well i sent him an email and i said i'm
sorry you know the some stuff i said was
maybe too far
that's nice and then he sent me back a
very sweet genuine email as well
apologizing so all right all is well
that ends well
all right
with dear nicocado
you know
the
um big nicocado fan on the crew
is actually with us right now
do we want to see what she thinks
she's on zoom oh olivia i'd love to hear
what she thinks of course she's the only
one that matters
yeah i mean olivia's the real victim in
all this because olivia
you bought the plane ticket you are
hyped you were the one driving this to
happen you were gonna pick him up in a
wheelchair at the airport what are your
thoughts on all this have you watched
all the videos and everything
i have watched all of the videos okay
[Laughter]
i mean i'm sad
obviously but
i think it was a misunderstanding in
terms of
who was joking who wasn't joking what is
okay to say what isn't okay to say and
as long as
you both are happy i'm happy
[Laughter]
well he senpai noticed you at least at
the end of the day and he knows your
name is very sweet toward the end yeah
yeah
i think in the in his uh
bowing out video didn't he say
olivia was the only reason he said that
in this video he said the only thing he
really feels bad about is olivia because
he heard that she bought a plane ticket
to come out and all that
so that was very sweet olivia i've been
listening the entire time
yeah how's it out there you all right
where are you freezing i'm in ohio
it is 21 degrees right now oh my god
yeah it's pretty crazy
um
definitely homesick
but also really happy to be able to
finish
epic
yeah thank you well olivia's gonna be
back in three months she's taking a
three-month hiatus to finish school she
will be back when she comes back hey
as a
degreed
a bachelored individual a ba and what
what or what's our degree in
it's in it's a liberal arts degree so oh
yeah
i have to cover everything but i'm a
drama major drama you are drawing
wait hold on what can you learn there
you're basically a drama phd
[Laughter]
all right well there you go see all's
well that ends well with nick acado
he stood me up
it was a date with destiny but uh hey
what can you do it is what it is
all right
thank you olivia
god bless god bless bless
so that's that you know so we have a lot
of things to get to today lots of fun
stuff yeah first of all right out the
gate before we get to the festivities
actually you know what let's start with
some festivities
let's start with
this this was my big
we've been working on this for months
okay it has to do of course with our
kelly oh
i'm gonna get your shots did you get
your passport it's all happening
okay
we got our kelly from prison
to make me a cameo he's on zoom right
now right now
uh that's not true
but here for those of you who are not
familiar r kelly did
a concert in ethiopia
yeah who the hell is that who hasn't
it's important
the volume on my side is a little low
zach if you could crank that thank you i
think every single view here is just
from us
it's got 1.4 million it didn't have that
much before this
i'm looking at 30 000 when i first
started watching it
go back and find out already underground
i think yeah yeah so
um here
kelly would you like to trade recruiting
to come to his
sex dungeon
[Music]
[Applause]
and nothing against the festivities
going much like sex trafficking am i
right
facebook
did you get your shots who would you
like to come back with
[Applause]
harmony
yeah
actually there's the whole monologue
before that we've watched a few times
too but what we've done
yeah this is kind of a bummer but we
still got it
our plan was to bring in a full
freaking choir
and by the way i think i found the first
time we ever watched it on the show but
unfortunately it was like one of the
only times ever that you full screen the
video the enter oh wait wait there's
like one frame
where'd it go
oh
you must have closed it here i'll search
i'm trying to see if how much we blew
this video up oh yeah yeah no i'm so
cute by the way the links are in here uh
guys there's literally
not the links they're in vmix
what
everybody makes the the things
200 000 views although this is on
ethiopian tv so this appears to be a
different uh upload than the one we keep
coming back to i feel like we did blow
that up yeah
that's some clout dude r kelly should be
sending me a christmas
she'll be sending me a christmas card
thanking me that's true
so my plan was to have a whole
freaking choir
to be offering me angelic
gregarian chants as i saying
but because of kovid
we are um
a little afraid of having so many people
in here yeah as ila goes closer and
closer to giving birth this could be
your last episode
i mean it can happen any day at this
point which is insane
and
so
obviously if you get covered like that
would be a disaster yeah totally i've
been super paranoid about it yeah
which is why we're all
wearing masks today but in lieu of that
and replacement of that we've got them
to send in a video so let's start with
the um
barbershop uh quartet we got two
versions we got the quartet and we got
the choir
i couldn't decide we got a quartet and a
choir interested and i said i want both
you gotta choose one no he's just like
no we're doing both yeah
yeah
so let's start with the quartet here
oh
let's settle down for a second so i can
talk to y'all for a second
i got a problem
the day before i got on the plane to
come out here me and my girl broke up
yeah
we broke up
[Music]
and it was over something
really really silly
something we shouldn't have broken up
over
but it is
it is what it is we broke up and here i
am in ethiopia tonight
question
is there anybody out there single
[Music]
they broke up with their man and they're
looking for somebody else right now
[Music]
you gotta be
single single ladies put your hands in
the air right now so i can see you
[Music]
there's so many
i'm confused
single ladies single ladies
now i would like to get to know you and
talk to you and have a drink or
something we can just have something to
eat and just
but at the end of the conversation at
the end of the conversation i'm gonna
want you to come back to america with me
i know i am
so you gotta be willing to split the
difference come to america and see me
i come out here to see you in ethiopia
but it's so hard to get back and forth
so hard to get back and forth that's the
problem how am i going to get you from
ethiopia
to america
let me think let me think
[Music]
do you have your passport did you get
your shots
girl would you like to come back with
rob to america
america
do you have your passport
did you get your shots girl would you
like to come back with rob to america
america
america
do you have your passport did you get
your shots who wants to come
back with love to america
america
a miracle
[Music]
to
america america
dude how good was that i mean i was i
was crying and [ __ ] and pissing
on the floor as i watched that
and what's really interesting is how
hard he nailed that monologue yeah
i got it
i got it and like he actually really
drives home how creepy it was
what am i gonna do
i got it
yeah
absolutely expressing enough how much i
love this song it's also just
it's messed up it slaps so hard
i'm surprised that never made it to one
of his albums because it slapped so hard
yeah but r kelly is a musical genius i
think this proves yeah
he is
i mean so is michael jackson yeah you
can't take it away from him yeah
this was amazing
so okay the quartet crushed it yeah
beautiful voice too
just perfect
well we have another one
the next one to the choir we should save
that for finale now back to back back to
back
we have to take a break too
we do yes
okay so let's do the ads and then we'll
we'll do that afterwards little
clickbait for you okay
no skipping
all right so when we come what would you
thank our sponsors we have only two so
and then afterwards we'll play the choir
but yeah paying homage to one of the
great saints one of the on this
christmas day
you know
but can you guys imagine if they were
here i was supposed to do
i was supposed to headline
i mean that guy had a nice voice but
nothing compared to me
that would have been epic
do you have your passport
did you get your shots
girl would you like to come back with
rob to america
america
okay
all right let's thank our sponsors hello
fresh
love hello fresh
super troopers love hello fresh
certified
bangers every time hello fresh uh is oh
abs burrito classic
everything
av made this lovely burrito what's hello
fresh
uh patella fresh you get farm fresh
three portion ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable and that's why
it's america's number one meal kit guys
we're talking hello fresh
hellofresh offers 50 manual market items
to choose from every week including
veggie calorie smart family friendly and
gourmet options providing plenty of
variety and recipes like hibachi sweet
soy
bavette steak and shrimp i'm sorry
what bring restaurant quality meals
right into your kitchen while their
white cheddar
wonder burgers make it easier than ever
to skip the take out hellofresh offers
flexibility you need during
to easily customize your order online or
in the app easily change your delivery
day food preference and plant size or
skip a week whenever you need to you
don't even have to think about it dude
right
i love hello fresh you know if you're
good at cooking if you're
no nothing about cooking
hello fresh is fun it's easy it's
affordable
the ingredients are always fresh it
comes with a little pamphlet that
explains how to cook it step by step it
explains about the food
and i've actually learned picked up lots
of tips and tricks about cooking
from doing the hellofresh
and the food for troopers love it these
are all from our from our discord right
dan
yes indeed people keep sending uh
pictures of them chefs in our chef shout
out to a barbecue chicken pizza yeah
that's uh
some sort of barbecue flatbread pizza
kind of okay
okay
whoa that looks bomb yeah some chicken
parmesan or eggplant
parm yeah love that
loving it
wow look at that it's healthy it's
nutritious it's delicious what more
could you want it's hella fresh go to
hellofresh.com after dark 16 and use
code after dart 16 for up to 16 free
meals and three free gifts they upgraded
what it was always 14. yeah they up yeah
that's 16 now what the heck go to
hellofresh.com after dark 16 and use
code after r16 for up to 16 free meals
and three free gifts america's number
one meal kit it's hella fresh thank you
and finally mint mobile
if saving
the audio is really i don't know if the
speaker's far away but i can't really
hear
the music yeah
just feels like very far away
if saving more and spending less is one
of your top goals for 2022 why are you
still paying insane amounts of money
every month for wireless switching
mobile is the easiest way to save money
this year as the first company to sell
premium wireless services only online
mint mobile lets you maximize your
savings with plans starting at just 15
a month
dan use mint mobile
yes sir
it's the best right it's the best
and it's a great deal what more can i
say i mean it's the same network same
network same backbone infrastructure
literally the same you get
from any big carrier but cheaper
and that's what we do around here at
mint mobile we like i own the company
that's what ryan reynolds do for people
looking to save extra money this year
mint mobiles offer premium wireless for
just 15 bucks a month by going online
only eliminating the traditional cost of
retail mint mobile pass is significant
savings on to you all plants come with
unlimited talk and text plus high speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5g network use your own phone with any
mint mobile plan and keep your same
phone number along with all your
existing contacts and with mint mobile
choose the amount of monthly data that's
right for you and stop paying for data
you never use push to mit mobile and get
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month people they get
your wireless plan for just 15 bucks a
month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com after
dark that's mintmobile.comafterdark
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com
after dark thank you
shredder
what happened never mind if nobody saw
it
he's climbing on the presents no oh okay
did he poopy
not not a number two but he just peed
yeah i wanted a present i pooped my
pants got him
nice
merry christmas from shredder shadow
what the heck pretty sure he just went
out too
shredder does this thing he's potty
trained yeah but whenever we get new
furniture or new rug or anything he's
got to pee on it yeah
he's just gotta let he just gotta let
him know that's awesome whose house it
is
hahahaha i peed in my basement
so anyway that was the quartet
now we have the choir
which we just received i actually
haven't even barely watched it
i haven't seen it
we pay that well okay i'm not gonna
maybe some details aren't worth
exposing not exposing but let's just
play the damn thing so here's the choir
one more time r kelly from the dungeon
on this beautiful early early early
christmas day go ahead
can i just talk to you for a minute
the day they got before i got on the
plane to come out here
me and my girl broke up
we broke
[Music]
is there anybody out there
that broke up with your man and you're
looking for somebody else right now
[Music]
you
[Music]
all the single ladies raise your hand up
right there so i can see who i'm talking
to
[Music]
so many
[Music]
but i know that at the end of the
conversation
i want you to come back to america with
me
i know i am
i know
[Music]
how am i gonna get you
from ethiopia
to america
[Music]
to see you
so hard
i'm gonna do this
[Music]
i
got
i got
do you have your passport
did you get your shot
girl would you like to come back with
wrong american
america
america
america
do you have your passport
did you get your shot
girl would you like to come back with
rome to america
[Music]
america
america
do you have your passport and did you
get your shot
girl would you like to go
to
[Music]
american
[Music]
wow
i love the american flag at the end
there's nothing more patriotically
american than sex trafficking yep salute
a part of me wonders if they didn't
understand
what they were saying
they were into it no they loved it yeah
but like the americans appreciated the
art either way it's a beautiful song
that's the thing we sent on the original
video
as like reference like they have
but but it's like the full con it might
just you know i don't know
well but i was surprised they're all
such good sports about it i think we
need to make it a tradition to get keep
getting
varieties of musicians yeah of bands to
reproduce this song
and i think like a hip-hop version a
hip-hop version would be fire
a couple people uh
immediately we linked it to them we're
like we got this big project and we
linked it and they were like no
okay yeah
they're yeah
interesting
just straight up pass huh well i'm glad
these guys didn't it's fast that was
amazing they were so up for it
yeah so maybe next we can get like i'm
thinking we can drop a full album
and r kelly's not suing us because he's
in prison what's he gonna do he's a
state might or something yeah
the state owns all of his ips now oh i
said his estate
ain't doing no but you might be right
there they might have seized all this us
welcome to taking a shot on it too oh
you sure i'd love to hear it oh
i think a crew version somebody
suggested a ska version definitely oh
yeah that's such a good idea
so what i'm thinking is throughout the
year
we should uh commission
of every genre we can okay and drop a
full r kelly do you have your shots do
you have your passport album i
would love that and i would listen to it
all the time oh yeah
just on repeat in your car dude
i want the whole country singing do you
have your passports did you get your
shot
girl would you like to come back with
rob
oh love you want to do the jubilee
before it gets like game green yeah sure
i just got it here
before it like developed flesh-eating uh
bacterial and microbes for about 45
minutes though i mean it's just fried
chicken i don't really think it's that
revolutionary i'm not worried i haven't
been ill yet for the record for anything
i've eaten
are you guys used to it because it's
still so weird to me i mean
it's here in the flash
it's on
it's not on the tablet oh
and these wise guys set it up so he's
right over dan's shoulder still that was
actually a complete coincidence
and it wound up but look how look at
that shot
it's just like he was on the love butt
there's no such thing as the coin there
really is
he looks like a projection like a force
projection
he's my little hologram everybody loves
your hat right away yeah shout out mf
doom all right try that try the chicken
all right so i don't know what the
difference is but i'm gonna get this one
um love is here from sweden he was
excited to try all of the american fast
food he had taco bell on the last
episode loved it
although this isn't even this is jabali
which is like
this is good it's really good he's not
saying it right it's right he's not
saying it right yeah because i'm
starting to get confused
jollibee
this is jollibee it's not even believe
it's a filipino uh
yeah yeah so this is just a regular
fried chicken i think very good
i told them to get the weirdest [ __ ] on
the menu for you do you have anything
else this is on friday stuff or uh i
guess spicy stuff oh there's spicy
chicken it's about a bit red i guess
where's my spicy chicken
i'm gonna take a bite away
crunchy my mouth is salivated just
watching them eat it
this one is a bit spicy can someone
bring me a spicy chicken please that's
not a joke i'm not joking right now
please i hear people leaving new year
but it's the same same ethan i like the
spice one more that was like the spicy
one more
all right where's the weird stuff
here's like some seafood pasta noodle
thing oh no what god's looks a bit gray
what in the god is that oh well yeah
it's called
fiesta hey
all right come on are you trying to turn
on all the ladies
yeah
is a noodle dish covered in garlic sauce
pork shrimp and egg
bro i am not getting fast food seafood
all right i hate shrimps i hate
egg
you hate egg yeah sorry
you know what you learned that's not
good it doesn't like
cheese
just straight up wait um
didn't zach also
not like cheese it's a cream cheese yeah
and uh any type of greek yogurt tomato
anything else yes i don't mind red cream
cheese it's just amazing what the [ __ ]
you throw tomatoes you are the only two
in the whole world
yeah so it's gotta be the only food in
european that doesn't like cheese i mean
that that really doesn't make sense no
i'm not i'm totally just alone in that
factory yeah
it's not a yeah but i like uh
she's on pizza i've been asking love
every day if how's his butthole feeling
and he said he's been fine so far so
good he's a young man
my butthole didn't start
acting up until i was like you know late
20s
okay early 30s maybe so i got a couple
years until that yeah what else you got
there you got it wow this is that's it
actually oh i got a pie i got a pie a
pie
mashed potatoes and all kinds of crazy
[ __ ]
yeah what's this
oh it's like a mcdonald's apple pie kind
of thing
[Music]
okay
hopefully it doesn't taste like the
banana [ __ ] you gave us
oh you should try some of that candy
it was pretty good
just a pie
it's just no you were there
such an idiot
okay
fantastic
should i rate it
do you like it yeah how does it compare
to taco bell
man i feel like it's not a fair
rating because it's a bit old but
considering the crunch was still there i
gotta give it a seven a seven taco ball
wasn't eight but was super old too
yeah sure
yeah maybe even older and it had been
sitting for a while right
uh yeah but probably a seven because
it's just fried chicken it's decent yeah
it's pretty good pretty good fried
chicken blow you away
right
oh
yeah that's it
well okay great
congratulations we love that
so we have
we're of course doing craigs miss today
like last year
ian got us all
free presents from craigslist
him and sam
we're also going to be doing a
prediction
for things that are happening in 2022
which we'll be able to check back up on
the end of the year
[Music]
we also have a recap that cam put
together which is incredible
maybe we should roll that eh can put
together an edit of a recap of all of
last year's
greatest moments and it's pretty
incredible
to see just how much
happened last year yeah
it's pretty wild there's a lot in there
that was like that was this year
i can't believe it actually we should
wait for elo she's gonna want to see it
oh for sure but there's so there's a few
things we can watch in the meantime
one of them is
dude
a lot of people probably don't realize
that me and elo were in a video game at
one point
and eli did hours of hours of voice over
work
like literally forgot about this this
was a crazy thing we flew to sweden
doing the voiceover ela's been scaring
the [ __ ] out of me i don't know i'm
showing a tick tock i have a youtube
video but we flew to sweden and they put
us digitally into payday two
really popular shooting game
and we did hours of voice over i see
where this is going
you guys are going to love honestly
since we've been doing the voiceover
ela's been scaring the [ __ ] out of me
you can see how she's dressed here i'm
like i'm always walking on eggshells
listen to this [ __ ] you they better fear
ela kill this [ __ ]
die [ __ ] maybe i'll go back to hide
in the bathroom while you guys do this i
care and i kill you i pulled all these
by the way
and they killed
honestly
okay so anyway that's the gestures of
tick tock but i pulled
a whole this guy on youtube made a whole
no
character pack playlist where you got
every voice line you did
six minutes worth of ela threatening to
kill people bro
so good first of all they wrote the
lines
i was just reading them uh-huh
but i'm still gonna why are you
embarrassed do you crush it you're gonna
hear myself it's it's awful dude you
were so freaking good in this
and you know ela's like
i feel like you overcame a lot doing
this yeah it was really hard
the first try was like
i sounded probably like cardboard and
they were like they kept trying to help
me
push through
yeah they had to kind of
well we had like a voice coach and stuff
yeah
it was hard but you're not a yeller you
don't yell anything ever i don't yeah
right right anyway
check this out you guys are going to
love this and zach is just creaming back
there
they're they're gold yeah i swear i saw
one other guy talking to his gun or
something it was weird
will this bane guy ever show up here
we were gonna steal a tank and keep it
in our garage but aldstone was like what
listen these are lines to other
characters in the hideout
so i'm just gonna go to the combat part
yeah
um i'm thinking about switching jobs
what do you think i should do
there's nothing happening here control
relax man you guys are so cool there's
no action here control i wish some
clowns would show up or something hey
you know i'm gonna need you to leave me
alone for a bit okay
hey control it's kind of boring standing
watch here i mean nothing is happening
sorry control just zoned out for a bit
[ __ ] control just leave me alone okay
are we gonna listen to the whole thing
misplaced my god but i found it it's all
good
hey control um wait let me get this
hands up [ __ ]
down
down get down and stay there
don't move
down hit the floor down get down
down hit the floor stop it please
listen
to people already
follow
i don't need to know that
on me or it's already been seen by the
whole world come on accept me
follow me you never watched it
get up
get up and fight
okay
hold on
where's the combat part here sniper come
on faster
they got a sniper
sniper
the sniper is dead
dozer
it's a dozer
a [ __ ] dozer i'm in physical pain
i remember that one you have to do it
like a it's a dozer yeah
it's a dozer and then they need you to
do it in different volumes dozer
and then medium dozer you're like no no
no too loud those are there
this is a closer this is like
harder than labor
this is so good the fans deserve to see
this they got a shield
it's a shield
shield
steel
i killed the shield watch the shield
the shield is dead it's good [ __ ] right
okay so zach which sound bites were you
able to pull from all this
nothing right yeah like six
there's like six minute videos so like
the best of the best so let me hear it
uh you got it a [ __ ] dozer the dog
down hit the floor
down get down it's so good [ __ ] no [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
that's so stupid no good no it sounds
awesome my favorite one is
i care
and i kill yeah
this is genius this is so good that
one's my favorite i don't believe any of
you
you don't want to mess with me
[Laughter]
this is nice you can't tell me that i
don't sound stupid you don't sound it
sounds badass
i people don't understand how hard it
was for her
but i'm glad we pulled those out of the
archive because i totally forgot about
that kill this [ __ ]
kill this [ __ ]
kill me by the way i have one too you
want to hear mine
ethan klein h3
i don't remember mine's the thing is
it comes so natural to you no mine was
bad people were dunking on me in the
game they're like ethan's are so [ __ ]
bad dude really and i remember that
ethan's [ __ ] sucks at voice acting
that's not true just pure maybe just
something
it's funny because um
everyone in the deals in the payday 2
community hated it that they put us in
the game
but we loved it our fans loved it
joey this is so [ __ ] stupid look
here's my fat ass do you know if the
weapons i buy for heist are tax
deductible
okay
that's a little stereotypical don't you
think i forgot about that
straight up the gate attached right off
joe oh my god
seriously
hey is that a quarter on the ground i
never remember that yeah any other
jokes like that hey is that a quarter on
the ground is that mine do you mind if i
take it
haven't we made enough money let's just
get some pizzas some soda pops our
troubles are over dude
i'm trying to lose the food
your character is though
wheelchairs
making videos pays [ __ ] compared to this
yeah
hey will somebody pass the baby wipes
so do y'all vape or nah
hey doc papa bless
we may be in washington but los angeles
will forever be my country
that was a jake paul joke it's a little
over the top
of jake paul jokes timeless
timeless comedy technically i got nick
crompton yeah all right shout out to nip
crofton
listen i love heisting the running's
kind of rough can you guys put me in a
wheelbarrow maybe and push me around
i'll do great shooting
this place man it's [ __ ] awesome
who would have thought it
look at this this
is success
hey dude i got like half a soda pop in
the fridge if you want it um
you do everyone was saying mine's
horrible here you want to read the
comments
so fun so john wick is also in the game
the top comment so if i understand
correctly ethan and eeler are now part
of john wick cannon
oh
that's pretty cool oh my god wait here's
a nice comment memes aside this sounds
amazing you see i like it i think you
have yeah
i would like it in a video game
if i was playing
no way
i'm looking for a for a hate comment
well the fact that you have to look so
much
yeah maybe it's not that bad as i
remember i think that's profitable i
wouldn't and they're all like
[ __ ] this dude man
i [ __ ] hate this drive
i mean i can see why like people just
like the game and then there's like this
two youtubers
yeah
there was only one i pulled from mirrors
um that really stood out it's this one
which i feel like could become useful i
feel like shrek and you're in my swamp
so stupid
that one's my favorite yeah that's fun
ethan is obviously not good at being a
voice actor there you go thank you long
legs whatever five left five likes
nothing four years ago wow
[ __ ] hate him dude
he's ruining the game great swords
wouldn't that be bad let's go to the
club we strike or something oh i think
my battery's running low i'll have to
replace it after my shift
i was in the uh bathroom for a minute i
was blasting ass sorry about that
it's okay control i was just it's still
a great game if you guys want to play it
it's on there the uh payday too on there
it's still like one of the most popular
games on steam isn't that crazy it's so
good in my hair
it was such a funny
awesome those guys are amazing yeah the
developers almir yeah who's a friend of
ours
uh starbury studios
down
down
and stay down
come on follow me
oh thank you
thank you i feel so much better
oh thanks resurrection
i took care of that dozer
by the way they kept being like louder
on the loud part right you're like you
have to scream louder i was like oh my
god my voice was getting absolutely
destroyed yeah we had like yellow lines
right and there's like red lines red
yeah they're like louder i was like what
the hell i have a podcast tomorrow
[ __ ] dozer
there's a [ __ ] dozer bro
it's one of the enemy units
there you go pretty pretty
pretty cool they better fear ela
that scared me
that was so loud and scary
so useful material
for sure
okay so now that you're back anyway i
wanted to play the recap video that cam
prepared yeah so let's go ahead and roll
that and afterwards let's get into
craig's mess wow
exciting stuff
i texted the doctor and she said you're
super pregnant
[Music]
yes
[Music]
okay guys feast your specific number one
wikipedia
i'm the foot god
you don't pass me this is my foot throne
there's been a
full-on wikifeed mutiny by the mods of
the website they have banned me outright
so weirdly now if you go to the top zach
you're number one which is like this was
never meant to be
those are joker toes
[Music]
between your legs
[Music]
[Music]
everyone saw that
[Music]
this is the first in studio interview
we've done in a year we are very honored
to have with us bella porch
this is so cool what kind of sam made
that
exactly like what i was wearing on the
music
i'm the chicken sandwich taco that has
now been discontinued i'm gonna let you
finish but zach had one of the best
performances of all time
olivia has been our intern she is
fantastic we love olivia
our new uh cast member so say hi cameron
hi cameron it's a very exciting to
introduce our new co-host mom
shave against the grain
that's how you know the monarch
butterfly is in so much trouble because
of the mexican cartel
ciao smash that like button thanks
everybody leftovers uh and i just wanted
to give you guys a shout out of well
wishes uh good luck with all of that
forward you don't want to [ __ ] your back
up why do you say that what do
we have a special ingredient here to
fill the hot tub with so you can just
get it all over me don't be shy now
okay good
awesome oh oh there he is oh no sam
cedar what up whoa what a [ __ ]
nightmare sam i'm never afraid
i can call out much
it doesn't mean that i'm looking forward
so these guys have beautiful hair and
you know i love an element of danger in
my life as well look at this bro this
guy's head is on fire and i want to do
it
[Music]
[Applause]
and this is a new person ian's favorite
person well here it's black friday we're
looking for some deals we're looking for
some crazy lines some door buster sails
don't pan that way don't pan that way
nail salon black friday we bought our
own
first edition
pokemon packs
this is not pokemon
desert storm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
zero gravity workshop
can i get it just imagine how cool i
would look on the show
[Music]
come forth to me
the wizard of hate and love
foregone of ego molded by the
machinations of the multi-monitor more
than one person is gonna smoke i'm gonna
bring them to my desk interrogate them
and see if i can figure out which one of
these guys is blaze
what's what's 20 times eight i'm not
doing math 20 times eight right now i
[ __ ] failed math five plus ten
fifteen times five
thirty
[Music]
times what does this mean to you
[Music]
i'm having ptsd right now
anyway so uh who's ready for the gender
reveal
[Music]
two h3 podcasts from elon
jesus
christ hey guys yeah i got a little
upgrade i'm turning off the wi-fi you
don't settle down
[ __ ] you
get the [ __ ] out get the [ __ ] out just
give me the seat i'll shoot you yo if
you don't [ __ ] settle down i'm gonna
[ __ ]
i'm gonna get the super soaker dude free
britney [ __ ] guys uh seems brittany is
free
really
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
there's no such thing as a coincidence
the fact that you're watching this video
means you are energetically aligned with
me
it's not a coincidence the first
influencer to ever talk about my tick
tocks
was
your show months
[Music]
you're going back to where it all
started
you're going back to the matrix
[Music]
keemstar made an appearance on aiden
ross's stream i just did a podcast with
tana mojo it was so raw so ready
that he didn't have feeling in his dick
why are you talking about my phallus do
you think really that these dudes want
to hear that i don't think that it's the
diss you think it is it's just such a
peaceful work environment except for the
occasional fight charlie demilio jason
nash david dobrik james charles jeffrey
star here by j leafy is here stephen
crowder lil tracy logan paul jake paul
greg paul the trailer company
i'm gonna bite my tongue
because there's plenty more i could say
about triller that i just want to be
nice for now
welcome to the ryan cavanaugh is running
a ponzi scheme podcast accused by his
ex-partner
yeah he's not running a ponzi scheme
he's been accused by his ex-partner of
running bingo in as reported in variety
all i've ever done is read headlines of
reputable
news organizations if you think those
are defamatories and take it up with
them family family family family family
family family we're actually having the
family over all right let's go eat okay
i always start right now all right guys
what a show huh
thank you everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah it was crazy how much happened in
that year yeah also considering that we
didn't even include
frenemies right at all in there except
for that last bit
what a year what a year what a year
biggest year by far thank you to all you
guys yeah tremendous hard work our
pleasure thank you to everybody who's
watching um what a year
you know without you guys watching we
wouldn't be able to do any of this stuff
wow what an honor what a thrill what a
joy what a joy
and unfortunate that we weren't able to
do that at the actual end of the year
it's a little odd doing this on the
end of the year
man
it's so not fair like
the the christmas vibes are in the air
when no in december right it was so
botched
and then i we won the lawsuit during the
break so we didn't really get to
celebrate that in real time one of them
whatever right we're all here healthy
look at the bright side
that's right the bright side
but he's definitely going to appeal so
we'll get to celebrate it again
okay only when we take that dub
or or one of the other many many laws
yeah one of the other 10 lawsuits that
he's currently uh they better fear you
the quality of the sound is like
shocking and it makes me feel scared
all right so i feel i feel emotional
watching all that because i i know that
um
like for the longest time this kind of
stuff were
hours and mostly your dream for the
podcast and i feel like it's really been
like
shaping up to be
what you've always wanted it's really
cool i agree you know it's it makes me
feel proud and happy looking over all
the stuff we do we've done over the year
the sketches the goofs the bits the
shows yeah the quantity of content we've
been making
you know the budgets that we've been
able to put out for the show to do all
these stupid gags and they get such a
big crew and yeah talented people that
can pull these things together on
a consistently short basis absolutely
yeah
so thank you guys for watching and
appreciating all the hard work we put
into this
and uh it's just it was an amazing year
it really was
started in the basement too that was
what tripped me out watching yeah like
almost half of the year we were still in
the basement yeah that's insane i can't
believe that there's really only six
months of studio time it's crazy when we
go down to the basement now it's like i
still remember when the whole thing was
just cables and like
three sets down there yeah
tripods
[Laughter]
i wonder if people are seeing this on
their feet and like what is this rerun
yeah from this old christmas episode why
would they probably need to re-title it
because they're like the christmas
special i said we should do the late
three christmas special the late three
late three yeah
i mean not everybody's gonna you're
right though our fans yeah i think
people are literally like this is
okay
what would be a good title for a late
christmas special
the late three late three that's just a
little inside baseball i i agree yeah
it's funny to us
we can also call it nicotto avocado
literally backstabbed me
i'd probably get the most
views yeah probably
uh the late are the late the chris i was
thinking the christmas special that
never happened
nick ruined christmas i mean that
doesn't even make sense
think that literally doesn't even make
sense
i mean half the time they don't make
sense though
good point yeah well the clickbait needs
to be it needs to activate some part of
your brain where you need an answer but
this one like this it just short
circuits
okay that's maybe fair because i was
thinking maybe you see that and you're
so confused
that you have to click
avocado ruined our christmas special oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's so nice to hear theodore's voice
during the show oh my god hit me with
that again
he tried that again on me the other
night but yeah
i didn't give him i was just like no no
no no i know
not funny we're not we're not doing it
it's so cute
what the heck
what do you think nick nicotta avocado
ruined our christmas special
but is it still sounding like a whole
episode yeah yeah
i think maybe no christmas in the title
oh [ __ ] yeah that's maybe you're right
if you really want to it just said
2021 year in review like that yeah
like where we make it clear that it's
about a retrospective kind of yes it
sounds boring
[Laughter]
i'm going back to late three late three
then people are saying no
nicocado nico cotto is the grinch that's
a good one
no nick in the title gape nation
somebody said oh my god oh my god
holy [ __ ]
oh how about uh 2022 is already ruined
that's a pretty funny one oh from emily
oh my boss that's
that doesn't make any sense no stop that
that's messed up too
is it though
i said he does his gaper looks like goat
xc by the way is that offensive
no
thankfully most people probably don't
get that reference no way people don't
get goat xc that one overnight i think
it's a really old meme you guys have
that picture of kermit the frog we're
not putting a go
but it's just kermit the frog it's like
totally safe for work
also there's pictures of like
uh natural cave formations that look
just like that xc
do you you know what that is right here
though yeah i know i know
what are you you're pronouncing it weird
goat c it's go c yeah yeah
go to it zach's like
those were the best times of the
internet when something like that
was so easy to troll anybody into
opening
the most vile shocking insane image yeah
it's
the internet was amazing back then
wasn't it
you introduced me to all that stuff
what happened
i don't know you're just like have you
ever seen this i was like bro you gotta
see this [ __ ] that was like my middle
school like lemon party one guy one jar
oh a laminated party forgot about lemon
party's nothing compared to goats yeah
goats
that's probably the worst
goatsee is a dude uh
like with both hands inside his you know
what
just spreading it wide and there's like
seemingly like a spotlight behind the
camera or something because you like see
like it's super illuminating in there
yeah that's a good point it's well lit
yes
it still works hard
it's well lit and that's what we like
about it
one guy one jar always gabe three gape
three people are saying
people saying pop girl something about
20 22 is already ruined or something
like that
no
nick cotto literally
was tub girl proven real or fake you
guys remember tub girl i unfortunately i
do i i couldn't tell you if it was real
you know i'm afraid i'm afraid to
fact-check it because i don't really
want to
i don't know it was a girl it was a
woman who was in a tub who was
projectiling projectiling from her
b-hole
into her mouth
okay is it different than two girls one
cup yes yes completely yes come on abe
two girls one cup was that pretty that's
real that one's real that is
well i don't know what they're eating
is real but no i think that one's real
i think we argued this um
i think one of the women like one of the
rumors was the person died from eating
the extra no way yeah don't say that no
no no no don't say that
we don't like to hear that
you better make sure before you say that
i bring that energy down sorry forgive
me
something about um rewind time it's
rewind time
someone's just saying two girls one cup
is fake actu
that was fake really i
i mean
yeah i think i think we did talk about
this a couple years we thought it was
real i think we
some people saying tub girl 100 real
people are gross do not understand yeah
yeah people are gross we debated if pain
olympics was real
and pain olympics was proven not to be
real at least the the the most infamous
one yeah
two fungurs one girl
anyway whatever but i do think we should
change the title because it's like
confusing i think stick your finger
stick your finger
so what is that one from because i'm
dan just missed oh
[Laughter]
this character to come back
stupid
all right let's move on let's let's
start preparing for craig's miss craig's
man
was a huge hit last year all right let
me uh
i thought about wearing the shirt that i
got last time but it didn't fit
what shirt did he give you last year i
got like a long sleeve um
what was it something about a hentai or
something oh you guys i would i wouldn't
i wouldn't put that on i was gonna had a
weird smell to it well the premise of
craigsman is that ian has searched far
and wide for free gifts on the internet
and he has got he's procured us
all a gift that he got for free
off craigslist
and that's craigslist it's a budget
christmas spectacular last year it was
such a hit the memes have stood the test
of time the cosby doll for example
was a
came back just recently yeah i mean it
was a hit throughout the whole year
[Music]
tried to match i looked everywhere for
some
some things to
to meet the hype and as i understand it
ian has um
outdone himself
huh
how is that possible
well he's been working hard i i
understand that him and sam were like
driving all across the country
practically wow sam you were doing like
hour-long trips to pick some of these
gifts up right
what'd you say
she said it's true yeah we had to do
some some drives yeah wow so
very excited
there's some huge presents i don't know
if you guys have seen there's one here
that's like
freaking enormous i'm so curious about
that one um
this is the holy grail we'll save it for
the last or a b can you stand next to it
for scale
yeah look at this it's massive is that
mine
who's that for this is gonna be for dan
oh
we love dan yeah he deserves we love
that yeah this is yeah got to give him
something special
we love dan
and is there a cursed one that we're
going to have to leave on zach's
doorstep
okay all right please don't [ __ ] with me
this year so are you presenting how does
this work
uh yeah i guess i'm gonna come over
there so okay come come join us
[Music]
very merry christmas to you all
did you hear that
what
what does that mean maybe said the cosby
doll is missing
really
better not show up at my [ __ ] house
you guys
by the way what about a late christmas
special
it's a new episode
we're good this time go ahead at the end
okay great
we're here a little we've made it
christmas is normally
jesus's birthday
but i just looked it up it's january
21st
so it's uh jerry traynor's birthday for
my carly
wait who's jared oh that's the jerry
trainer
[Applause]
from what hawkeye
no that's jeremy renner oh who's jeremy
traynor crazy steve from jake and josh
is that him yeah i think so okay yeah
shout out shout out to character so what
does that mean that it's his
birthday instead of jesus
and jared happy jerry missed everybody
uh i guess we could start with you ethan
let me let me bring this or how about
you come over i guess
yeah there you go it's been a while
since i've
stood up with a microphone hey how's
everybody doing thanks for coming out
here today so how should we like sit
down and do like a christmas uh gather
around the
okay
well this is yours
what do you want me to say cross-legged
or something go ahead yeah ever put it
right on your
[Music]
look at that look at that form
right
yeah my asshole's sticking out
all right we got a card
hi shredder
is that that that you might be sitting
right where shredder took that little
pee actually
do ethan
wow heartfelt
hi alfredo hi schrader
all right here we go
beautiful wrapping job it says i believe
in santa
which is true by the way
this was a pretty good find i had i had
to i had to hunt for this one so
sam wrapped it very well we have just
basically a
cardboard box that looks like it's been
thrown around by a disgruntled amazon
worker
hard with one hand but i'll make it
happen here we go
all right opening it up
let's see here
it's okay i got it
so
okay wow no
freaking way dude
you had you bought this
no way you got this for free not
everything's free but it's all at a deal
i deeply bartered for everything here yo
we got the jordan peterson bust
this is actually
is this the one that was for sale no
this is a rare
punished jordan bearded
jordan
his eyes are so close together on this
it almost looks like
something ain't right with them
but i don't know if you can tell up
close but tell me there's lore here i
mean this is powerful i'm pretty sure
the guy i got it from made it
i got it on
uh craigslist so
i think he only said there's like 50 he
made 50. wow so this is rare jordan this
is a rare jordan peterson bust and you
know these are these are actually
priceless because they were selling them
online what was it like 500 bucks dan
and and jordan was promoting it himself
a a humble man yes
so actually now i remember i
i low-balled hard what was he asking
i can't remember the exact number but i
low-balled and he was like
no and i was like
i responded and i sent a bunch of uh
lobster emojis
anyway for that i'll give you the deal
wait yeah laughter emoji but then does
that mean he doesn't like jordan because
lobsters is like no jordan has look at
his
so you sent him the lobster emojis
because his thing is the lobster yeah
and i got a good deal
wow yeah what was the guy like that made
this was it weird vibes or after energy
after i sent that really
ease the tension and you know vibes for
you to give off alpha energy yeah or
maybe one one of the other ones or gamma
or something sigma sigma energy
theta and pay the energy yeah wow can
you tell me how much you paid for it
i really wanna i have to check i
honestly it's been so long i don't
remember the exact number right well
this is amazing present i'm gonna honor
this
i will not be doing a come tribute on
this or anything like that
just to be clear i will respect jordan's
bus disappointing by not busting on it
wow
all right okay
fantastic man
thank you so much santa israel
he's real today
uh
okay next up i'm trying to thank
[Music]
cam
cameron cameron cameron
cameron is very nice he's coming out
mr cam grants we love him doing a
fantastic job
[Music]
we got you
sam is it the to the top
no it's all crooked one under the
surface okay
there's a top box okay
it's these two okay should i open first
cam's got the double go ahead and open
this first this one okay yeah
so that thing
looks so crazy
dude what the hell it's very realistic
this is uh related to
a artist that cam is a huge fan of
[Applause]
he has uh spoken about this artist many
times to us
off the show
so we got them first this is part one of
two okay a bottle of ketchup it's themed
okay so keep opening i guess yeah is it
john kerry go ahead and read a read the
name of it on the front
uh heinz tomato kit ed ship okay can i
ask a question yes did you get a deal on
that ketchup or was that full price this
was a good deal
it's so make sure you haggled for that
too it's tomato
edge up
it's uh
ed sheeran themed ketchup oh
this is real
deeply deeply expired
what's the expiration date
uh what is the date on this
do we know sam
sure it's spoiled that's pretty wait why
would they why are they making it is
that why it's dark
yeah i think that's why it's a little
blood red
cam loves ed sheeran
is that
and we also to commemorate his love of
ed sheeran we went ahead and made him
something you're going to want to go
show that to the camera
so it's
this it's uh
ed and me
wow this is worth its weight in coal
we
wow captured some of hold it up to the
camera cam and ed's best moments
together
flip it go ahead and flip through on a
road trip
halloween oh my god ed sheeran yeah
up to no good a couple bad boys
hanging out
there they are again the bad boys of
britain cam i did not know you were
friends with ed sheeran that's huge can
we get him on this show oh totally yeah
we go way back so this one was them at
disneyland a couple of funny bffs
he thinks i'm crazy and i know he's
crazy
ski trip together oh my god yes i
remember that well are you guys in a
romantic entanglement uh you know we
like to grab each other's [ __ ]
on it
one in the coop and a couple of styling
dudes
looking swagged out of course
the basketball game oh yeah ghost sounds
are you throwing up a wu-tang signal
what is this oh see uh edwin and he's
the knicks fan and he won that just
throwing a dub out cam's holding up to
hell his team lost unfortunately we'll
get him next time doing the shot couple
of boys at the sistine chapel when they
went to italy and uh
wow
cameron i didn't know you had such a
deep friendship
yeah i mean i'll see what i can do to
hook him up on the show now that we have
a spot for a guest coming up what is
actually the lore here you do not like
it i [ __ ] hate it why do you hate him
so much i [ __ ] hate him i can't i
think he's the most boring musician on
earth every photo of him is cursed i'm
sorry it is
his tattoos are cursed as well exactly
yeah his tattoos are horrible but if
you're an ed head out there i'm so i'm
you know it's just not for me i'm in
love with your body yeah but i [ __ ]
hate him all right numbers say otherwise
maybe this will change my mind you know
interesting cam you don't seem like a
hateful person but you have an
inordinate amount of hate for edge
something about the man just really sets
me off i don't know what it is
maybe in a past life he like really
screwed me over or something but i can't
stand him but you know i i'm very
grateful for craig claus here going
through the effort
ketchup yeah what the hell is this ed
sheeran
why does that exist
we were searching
ed sheeran items
on
craigslist and that's all
that popped up and so we got it but it
felt like we could get them a little
more so we have to wait i need some
background on this edge sharing ketchup
enjoy it go put it on the jelly bean
good ketchup i'm sure it would be great
um maybe we should maybe we could smell
it
should we crack it you don't want to
break the seal on that yeah maybe not
maybe
that'll that'll go up in value i mean
here's photos they did
uh uh
cam look at this this might help
raise your appreciation
why did he make a ketchup with time i
just don't i just want to understand
here let's go to the website
here it says
ed sheering loves ketchup like really
loves ketchup in fact he loves it so
much that one might argue a
collaboration between him and the
world's most notable ketchup brand was
inevitable
and now it's finally happened ed sheeran
and heinz have made etch up
a reality just in time for national
catch-up date really i wonder who made
that was it hines
did they really need help selling
ketchup i mean like
it's so stupid it's already in every
house i want to make a national uh teddy
fresh day where everybody goes buys
teddy fresh it's a national day
everybody
there was actually a guy
on ebay who had like
a special commemorative box edge up like
one of ten
and he would not part with it for lower
than like 400 dollars wow yeah
yeah that that is not the spirit of
craigsman i know i tried to bargain now
did you buy this bottle
uh the one that we got yeah we was it
expensive no no
in the spirit it was deeply discounted
was it more or less than an actual
bottle of heinz ketchup believe it
actually was lower in value
depreciate it a little bit it's actually
real and you'll be able to get your
hands on one very soon ed shop this is
not the collaboration that anyone asked
for or needed bro
this is just ridiculous
we love the ginger fury
nickname of ed somebody the top comment
on this post is by
someone with a thousand followers said
slurp me like you slurp that ketchup
[Laughter]
and another person said shame on you
with puke emojis [ __ ] and then shame on
me yeah yeah straight up just shame on
you here look
she hates it
shame on you
mr ed sheeran
how dare you you sick twisted freak
okay well that's well that's some good
lord that's actually a good story a
great gift it's a craigsmith miracle it
is yeah glad to make that happen for cam
uh love
could you love is here person to receive
his gift what a
it's magic oh christmas miracle butts
and i should get olivia on the line for
this too right she needs to see this so
unfortunately we
were meant to do this
back in december where love was not here
so i don't have a thing for love
unfortunately hey olivia welcome back
have you been on the whole time yeah
that was fast
[Music]
i've been watching
i always watch
olivia's the best isn't she folks
so
because of well love being here i didn't
want to leave them empty-handed so
this gift it was for olivia she's gone
he's taking her seat so they will have
to be sharing
because of sharing one gift that's fine
now before you open that there is a
conspiracy amongst the audience that you
guys are the same person sure yeah i
love it yeah thoughts on that thoughts i
mean i can't disprove it right here now
but how can we just how can we prove
that olivia's not a pre-recorded message
to me to cover up that you guys are the
same person
um i don't know you tell me
okay let's try to how can we prove right
now that these are two different people
we can't
olivia hold up two hands
two now put down your thumbs only
blink your left eye
open your mouth for five seconds and
close it
that's the real that's real yeah that
that's infinite how could i plan that
how could i no am i no
it could have been scripted i don't know
it could have been
the whole thing could be scripted all
right
uh so olivia you had said before that
you were going to let love have this
gift
right you said that you were going to
forfeit it
uh well
that depends see now you want to wait
let's see yeah yeah
so i can only see ethan and ela by the
way oh i see
okay i feel like you got to decide now
who gets the gift you can't i want the
gift there you want she wants it
okay love if you if you really really
want it let me know no i'll let you have
it don't worry
awesome
i'm excited to open this though
all right so we're waiting can you see
olivia can you see the
now i can okay yeah
all righty
you wanna hold this go ahead yeah drum
roll
yeah be very delicate is it a cut a car
or cut out of trisha's
ex-husband brad pitt
time will tell
very delicate
it's got to be a cut out
[Music]
okay it is a cutout oh i know what it is
we should i see kind of a golf dress
[Music]
you know what it is i still don't know
what it is
yeah
oh
[Music]
oh my god
wow wow wow
wow what an alpha he's very tall
so are you happy with your decision
i am
so incredibly happy with my decision
oh i am too
right
so
what's the story here ian
uh
yeah this was i was searching for some
cutouts and uh this one just happened to
pop up and i know
was this the first time olivia you
really
praised pete on the show i think was
talking about
the met
i think so i think i was upstairs
screening calls and i had a lot to say
that's what i had to put down so i've
done this with the intention of you
having some company in your shot from
now on
but since you're not going to be here
this might have to live in love shot
for now i'm okay with that if love's
okay with that yeah for a while maybe
an episode
we set up a marriage kind of uh like uh
trisha did ready to the beat david
said pete davidson pete davidson
yeah pete david yes sir yes set up a
marriage maybe
not wait to meet him what are your
thoughts on him dating kim by the way do
you ship that or no
i just it feels so bizarre right
yeah i don't see it seems like a cloud
move
i don't get it
if they're
happy they're happy
but i would love to date him one day so
are you upset that he's not single
i'm not i don't i don't necessarily
think i would have a shot but right
okay
never know
well congratulations this is a really
thank you so much so you're doing make
it you found that we found it yes did
you buy it or we're giving it for free
we we got a bargain we got a bargain
and there's stuff people sell on
craigslist and the people buy it too i'm
secretly just blowing all of the show
budget on these items very expensive
uh okay next
isn't kanye planning like a diss track
on pete
he did a said a thing in a song yeah
about how he was gonna kick his ass bear
him or something really what did he say
do you know he said that pretty much
like um
he said uh
i survived the crash because he almost
died on car crash
so i could beat pete davidson's ass is
it really pete's fault i mean kim's no
it's really kim's the one that's but
also kanye's dating it's a model i mean
what what's the double standard here
yeah i think the whole thing's kind of
ridiculous but um yeah
uh
maybe i'll send him a cutout too
yeah we'll get him a cup we'll get him
yeah to ease some tensions yeah
uh so the next one
oh
okay
let's do it baby
now this may be
this is kind of a i'll swap with you to
do the camera
this is kind of a two-parter
so i'm gonna have to send you a link oh
wow okay on discord
that you'll open up
you can do it
okay i'll send it in the discord then so
here you go
thank you ian
baby please stand up i gotta be on the
left stand up baby
you can open it though okay i'm gonna
sit on the floor because
oh he's got it ready to go okay
all right well go ahead baby open it up
okay
oh is this difficult with one hand hold
on
oh okay
it looks like a shoebox
k swiss okay squeeze
don't recognize it y'all recognize that
uh signature
no [ __ ] way
are these gary v's k-swiss
holy [ __ ] how did you know about that
you got me some air gears
yeah
are these retro air gears wait but is it
one shoe is there two shoes in there is
there so like a metaphor
yeah it's um yeah it's a signed shoe by
gary vee
now love unfortunately
well in the spirit of gary i kind of had
a forward thinking idea
so love if you could bring
if you could bring that up for me being
friends
on openc i think i know where this is
going
go ahead and click the second link
we'll go to the other one first but
yeah
so i took
i took the uh right shoe and i threw it
in the garbage
and i decided to mint it
as an nft instead so this is a
sensational shoe that's incredible is
there a video of you drawing it in the
description yeah go ahead and click that
link just to prove authenticity
yeah just like
himself
so
now can he wear this shoe in
uh this nft yeah absolutely not no you
can't can i sell it
uh you can try
uh maybe you can
you know scam one person it's just one
shoe who's gonna buy that
unfortunately it's not a full pair of
nfts
that's a really good drawing yeah yeah
that is actually pretty good that's
enough yeah we bring a lot of snow we
bring a lot of quality to ian friends
if i sell it
oh i definitely will have royalties
turned on about 90
so if you could actually click back it
comes with a bonus it's not the left
shoe but this one right here oh this is
beautiful this is this is frenching
fossil this is actually valuable i feel
like yes so
so this is for abs getting this yes wow
this actually you could sell i feel like
okay
i wanted some gary friends nfts for
christmas but this is even better you'll
find out this is way more valuable
actually the bottom of the shoes sure it
says the mission the motive
the macro
the what
the mission the motive the macro oh the
macro what an [ __ ]
[ __ ] that guy
you know
as a gary v fan one shoe's enough i'll
just hustle now it's the mission it's
the mission it's the macro it's a
statement
thank you guys wow wow that's a really
nice gift congratulations thank you i
didn't okay how is he going to receive
those nfts do you have a wallet or
something i've got a wallet um
we don't have to worry about it right
now but we'll figure it out i didn't
know case bliss was still around to be
honest but
i'm honored
what's the deal with those collabs you
made a shoe with k-swiss and just like
scribbled on it yeah
yeah he did
he seems to be the driving complex in a
lot of his projects
complex clone exclusive shoes so
and so
what that must have been expensive to
buy right with all of his fans um
surprisingly no
i got a good deal
uh size 12 only a few sizes too big but
you know what it's all about the digital
right right right
uh so yeah there we go thank you well
shout out that's a that is actually a
tremendous gift high
yes
uh congratulations jb thank you i know
big moment
the first ian friend ever
okay i believe we're in the home stretch
here so now we're going to do elas
now
unfortunately
so i tried to find as much stuff on
craigslist as possible but
there was a couple you know
it was harder to find as good cursed
stuff this year i struggled a little bit
so for this one i enlisted the mad
scientist sam
to help bring something to life here an
art piece you could say
really yes and we're very curious to see
what this looks like
okay uh because it was meant to be
opened a while ago so
interesting this may be my favorite item
um this is okay
we could put it on the desk too i guess
if you want to sit ela squatting like a
king
that baby
you can still squat part of my yoga um
maternity yoga give birth
all right we got a box pretty pretty
standard sized box there
euless tearing it
open it might be a little heavy so
oh my god
expressing shock
huh
ian is taking it out of the box whoa
oh my god
so
[Music]
hold it up go ahead and lift it from the
base
it appears to be some kind of resin
project
this is the arby's meat mountain oh my
god dude no way frozen
in resin
is it molded at all who did the resin
sam sam was it hard
dude that's so cool
oh my god that's so cool
he's so cool wait there's a light no
freaking way
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this is the most cursed thing i've ever
seen in my life insuring is so horrible
that's pretty sick
are you going to put that next to your
bed
next to your bed
our bed
are on your bedside table
so is it decomposing
does it preserve it in the resin i'm
somewhat curious
take a peek at that wow this is
incredible
guys this is so pretty amazing i'm ready
to i'm ready to bust in here and eat it
take a bite
it looks pretty well preserved actually
um wouldn't you agree yeah i wonder
what's gonna happen to it
yeah i wonder i mean
it's probably fairly well
insulated from oxygen and stuff yeah you
can see kind of the bubbles that was uh
air like in the bun yeah that escaped oh
but uh could be decomposing bubbles
yeah but the sandwich is pretty intact
we could probably crack that open for
you if you want to
wow this is incredible what a what an
honor hilo
i'm just going that's a real piece of
art
in our behind the scenes for this week
we have a little clip of sam's process
you know we can combine our gifts yeah
little
peterson mountain
it's an alpha trophy right there oh yeah
look it says number 10 out of 50. wow
yeah on yours
doesn't it don't his eyes look a little
too close together
i mean
it's very good though for
okay so so thank you guys this is
amazing that is incredible yeah it is
kind of artistic it is totally
preserving history
so
the dogs are very fascinated by this one
for a certain reason
if zach could make his way over here oh
no you better not put his [ __ ] in the
resin
you guys resonated
we found the house that belongs we found
the lawn
it was still there
uh so
and same thing make sure it stays flat
when you open it
um zach was i don't know the last thing
i'll be saying
the last couple months getting so mad at
me for not coming up and going if you
give me cursed [ __ ] i swear he was
getting so mad so i tried to avoid it a
little and get something actually cool
what what's in there man what the [ __ ]
shredder alfredo it might be slightly
cursed vibes i don't know it's not
cursed it's not cursed
but you can go ahead and [ __ ]
go ahead and pop it open i don't want to
really i decline the gift you don't want
to do no no
no no no
i just i'm getting a vibe man
okay let's let's let's break this down
zach
the cosby doll
yeah [ __ ] might have been [ __ ] my
life up how has it [ __ ] your life up
you're fine everywhere your life is
great
right speechless he got you check me
for [ __ ] that means you gotta open it
you said open it flat
what did you guys put in there
all right this is actually pretty cool
sam instructed him to open it flat which
makes me very curious alfredo
alfredo come here you want it alfredo
no
don't bring that bad juju back in our
house alfredo
try to stay here all right so we've got
it open
i'm seeing green [ __ ] is this boils
it shredder shredder shredder
shredder shatter wants it bad
this is kind of a sick case though i'm
not gonna lie it's like a suitcase with
green boils on it
hold it up zach wait don't hold it i
can't
turn it down you gotta keep it flat
[Music]
can you not little flip
okay so it's faces on the suitcase right
is it my right yes
are they specific faces what is going on
in here
thanksgiving oh my god
are you serious no no no it hasn't been
sitting there since awesome touch
we got on the touch literature and and
the stanley tucci cookbook
thank you wait can he eat that steak is
that really ready to go that steak is
ready go ahead and have a bite of this
is there one more thing what is this
is this the fork and knife oh utensils
yeah we thought of everything wow
where's the twist yeah what's the
[ __ ] twist we've we thought it's kind
of an anti-twist oh it's in that x's
steak or something
what's up with the case
the case is a little sketchy and might
stink a little if you get a good show
show the case please the front of it it
looks crazy
what i mean that case is cursed did you
find that under like a cursed bridge or
something
it has a little bit of a cursed vibe to
it it was at the bottom of a well
what what give me the [ __ ] story
so i've looked for this case
uh
everywhere like another one of them
does not exist this is a one of one wow
uh there's a brand on the back of it it
says head case
i can't find this brand like show the
other side everything well we did we did
find one other from the brand we found
one photo of a suitcase from this brand
unlike a horror forum
[Laughter]
and uh i don't know what
it's maybe they put you know
it's like the heads of people that they
put in the suitcase and they tried to
break out no it's [ __ ] dope but i
appreciate it but are you gonna eat that
food zack no wait the steak this is your
thanksgiving stick i feel like look at
sam she just cooked this look at her sam
did you put
it's a freaking
[Laughter]
yes this is huge what's up with the case
tell me then i'll take a bunch of
jessica i'm gonna i don't want anything
that's like is it no tell me what's up
with the case it that case kept it warm
i can't wear that that's true
i feel like there's some dark [ __ ] with
that man what do you think it transfers
the food yeah kinda yeah it was keeping
it warm and secure i don't want it
what if a b tries it will you guys
ruining christmas yeah okay so abe takes
a taste this guy's ruining jerry miss
shadow jerry though
um
can i ask some questions what is your
fear zach where has this been
right are you afraid of germs or curses
purses i don't want that in my body man
not germs i got too much [ __ ] going on
okay so hypothetically speaking it could
have been
owned by someone like a bad
spirit or john wayne
sam uh samwin picked this one up for me
what were the vibes from the guy you got
it from he was super cool he had good
vibes what do you look like i don't feel
like that's what you told me can you
pull okay well can you zach can you hold
up the suitcase so we can see it while
we discuss it
thank you i know if it's sick as [ __ ]
don't get me wrong it's like a tool it's
kind of rock and roll yeah yeah it's
sick alex jones but
the dude was so sad to part with it i
thought he was going to cry he like
really wanted to talk
wait why did he get rid of it
i don't know did he sell it
uh yeah he did sell it how much was it
expensive no no it wasn't how much was
it did he just give it to you
no
you have to to
to properly convey the energy you have
to make a transaction you can't give it
for free
energy yeah good energy
hold it back up zach we got to see the
case um you're being tomatoed zack by
the way
[ __ ] him no
zach has he has
listen guys he is superstitious don't
you exact but zach if there was a curse
would it have already transferred to you
by holding it i feel like it's on the
stage it's a beautiful story it's on the
stage
on this day it's specifically even
how are you gonna
criticize your grandma for not making
the steak i got my mistake i finally got
it we gave you the steak
and you won't eat it
what the [ __ ] is the story with this
we told you you're not telling me now
what do you think zach he begrudgingly
got rid of it like what do you why do
you think he
if he loved it so much why didn't he
keep it there's some [ __ ] up people in
this world man right i think the five
faces were the five
previous owners actually of the suitcase
that's like some halloween town [ __ ]
all right hannibal lecter okay uh okay
av is going to take a bite of the cursed
stay i'll take a bite you take it and
then zach will follow oh you guys can
kind of do like a lady in the [ __ ]
thing yeah
yeah
you guys want to meet in the middle
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
how does it taste guys
pretty good
that's a huge cookbook right there man
good quality man
so how do you feel zach that's a [ __ ]
good stick man
you're gonna keep eating it
a little more info about the case and
we'll talk well unfortunately now i
gotta tell you you're [ __ ] i'm so
sorry
wait did zach spit it out yeah
what does that mean i'm just kidding man
no you're not i'm just kidding
the [ __ ] what does that mean
you got a
cannibal mask on i don't understand this
fear hannibal so it turns out and i'm
privy the owner of the suitcase is a is
an ex-con he did do time in prison for
essay and uh
essay basically and kidnapping that's
[ __ ] up that's not nothing about that
in the craigslist why would i want this
don't worry about it
how do you run a background check on
this guy
i just made that up
i don't know anything about the case i
just made that up
why did you say i'm
[ __ ] because look at your real [ __ ]
why did you say i'm [ __ ]
because you what everyone knows the
rules man
what rule
everyone knows the rules what rules
the moment
come on you're gonna have to make me
walk you through it he's eating the
[ __ ] steak
it's good it's really good wait is the
asparagus not cursed no it's amazing why
just the steak is cursed you can't you
can't curse asparagus
it doesn't accept it i'm holding spit
out chewed food in my hands oh tell me
what's up with the case that's
that's a round of applause
tell them the story so we can move on in
we just bought you a cool case it's rock
and roll [ __ ] it's metal
no it's not [ __ ] but what's the story
behind it there's no story
this is how i'm really getting in your
head because you think there's a story
you're [ __ ] with me right now
what's that are you about for
i just want to know what's up with it
there's no story to the case man he's
actually upset
yeah no zach's really upset right i'm
terrified
i'm standing here with chewed food in my
hand
i got nothing to say somebody in the
chat said those are the faces of the
members of ccr on the case right no
[ __ ] shot
did you see the
going around the hassan ccr meme no
because he had like a mustache oh i
didn't realize we're going to see our
thing all right well i'm sure this com
this conversation will continue off
camera you guys can sort it out i'm
pretty sure zach that it was just a
random dude and there's no story yeah
he's just some dude they found on
craigslist [ __ ] yes they just
found a weird case to put a stake in for
you yeah
just a state case okay did you do a
background check on the guy no
did you check the sex registry no sex
offender registry
no okay so
chance of a curse but we can't confirm
100 percent
i'll take that
all right so get yours get your book in
your case i'll take the book i i don't
want to take it you got to take the case
i don't want to
it's wrapping up zach come on just take
it no let's grab it he doesn't have to
take it zach we'll just wrap it up we'll
say you know thank you no thank you
you you chewed the steak and spit it out
we almost got you there because he he
was kidding i don't i don't trust this
man he literally was joking
he said now you're [ __ ] when you ate
the steak
well amy will you take a pet of the
steak to prove to zach that the curse
isn't real maybe he took everything yeah
you're just casually eating
bite of a potato how about that
are the potatoes aren't cursed
potatoes where's the logic there is yeah
potatoes absorb all the flavors and
everything like if anything's going to
absorb a curse it'd be a potato
steak you know zach i've got a theory
for you you know how steaks you don't
have to cook very well it's because they
don't absorb
from the outside very well you just have
to cook the surface a potato absorbs
everything so if the curse you know the
steak is going to be the least curse the
potato the most cursed well now we're
both [ __ ]
no
just you you're the owner it's just
all right wrap it up get the [ __ ] out of
here thank you very much all right all
right enjoy your case [ __ ] you giant
oversized cane time to drag them off
stage
all right
wow that turned into a whole thing
didn't it a really cool case yeah that
case is sick dude
that is very superstitious
you know
you really got him good but now you're
[ __ ]
i showed the case to everyone beforehand
and everyone was like oh that thing's
sick it is sick that's a cool case
there's one of one i think he's still
traumatized by the cosby doll and the
cursed bran
he's on edge he's on edge i could have
really i found something i found a doll
and the ad said uh
please take this from my home
nothing good has happened in my life
since my god
oh my god just get it out free
oh my god and it was really creepy
looking and i i couldn't i thought i
thought
how was it dude you got to get that and
just put it in his trunk with that post
i almost i i said sam shut
should i go pick this up and she goes
you're not bringing this in this house
not at all zach no
zack he he was talking about a present
he found on craigslist that was way that
was like super cursed and he didn't do
it because he didn't want to spook you
too bad well i appreciate that thank you
yeah see i'm looking out for you man me
and zach just wash our hands and he
looks me down in the eye and goes
honestly what the [ __ ] was what's up
with the box
yeah i'm saying zach is very
superstitious and uh that's fine
you know i don't [ __ ] with the bad [ __ ]
man and i get it
and we're bringing out the mother lode
here
this is like looks like a full on
reindeer or some [ __ ]
now who is this for was this a trojan
horse
oh for dan right
straight wheeling it out yeah steve
crowder's in there
okay
the final
so ian i i think you need to come back
here and switch again so i can go over
there yeah one second
so dan's gonna come
switch with ian
we have by far the biggest present
um
massive
this was fun to move upstairs
pretty heavy eh
surprisingly lighter than it looks so
okay interesting dan thoughts initial
thoughts do you have a mic
yeah um
i've been looking at this all week
uh
i really my only guess was like a
reindeer it's like vaguely reindeer
shaped yeah it looks animal shaped
but that's really all i've got that's a
fair guess
that's a fair gas
yeah i think that's a re that's a
reasonable guess for sure okay well then
it's that's probably what it is
all right well should i do it tear in
tear into
this is uh
maybe
the
peak of my craigslist experience that's
requiring this item we're faking dan is
tearing in
there's a lot of rapping
uh we can't see it the audience can't
see it from that side
so
here we go
i see
a
it looks like a maybe a giant mouse
or something
oh my god what
yeah
it's a giant mouse
that is a giant plastic mouse there you
go dan
what you've always wanted
is this what you've always wanted dan
he's been asking me and asking me you
know god what the hell is this what
why did dan get this of all people
i told you he it seemed like such a damn
thing
i saw it and it just screamed dan
you guys kind of have like a matching
thing going on
that's true they are kind of matching
colors uh
related dan are you gonna bring that to
your house
at least you're not gonna leave it in my
basement like last year
don't speak too soon
you better not [ __ ] and dump it on your
front lawn
can you um profile side a little bit so
uh the people can really uh admire its
majesty yeah that's good what the hell
is those
uh questions do you have any questions
for ian dam
i gotta say
are you sure it's a mouse
i think it's a chinchilla
okay
it's made for you it kind of looks like
a chinchilla you even know what it is
what the [ __ ] is that pull up a
chinchilla
let's see what i'm talking about
chinchilla dan is correcting the record
it's not a mouse
which is why it's the perfect game you
get white you get why dan got it yeah
100 now i think you're right it does
look like it
looks like a chinchilla
or a bad artist made it
or or well let's not insult the artist
no it looks like a chicken what's the
story behind this why do you say that
the chinchilla just looks like a
glorified guinea pig well because its
ears are a little bit more
chinchilla-like than
well maybe not maybe it is already ears
well do you have any intel on if this is
a chichilla or a mouse yeah what's the
story
well i linked the uh craigslist post to
you ethan and discord if you want to pop
that open okay fantastic let's see if we
got any
um this was the only thing
uh oh wow there's a lot of memes some
people are saying it's a rat
i don't think it's definitely a rat oh
really
wait what the [ __ ]
ian what the [ __ ] bro
that was that was the oh my god no
this would have been a good one for jack
for this large
vinyl rodent well just a rodent
yeah it really could be
any of the above
that's a good deterrent for intruders
i don't know i feel like the body of a
rat would be like
different
bigger
important did you so ian when you
decided that this was going to be for me
yes did you know that growing up i had
pet rats no but see
you just have the energy i just have
read and i have this thing i just got it
i hate to tell you guys but it's
definitely a rat i mean really yeah i
mean look look at the body though that's
so different the chinchilla ink is ain't
nothing like this thing this is a wrap
yeah the the size of the arm it's a
little bit like your chinchillas they
just have a little bit more heft to them
but
yeah that is very ratty isn't it
yeah what are you gonna do with it dan
look at the picture i said dan your
camera is freezing by the way
elo's trying to prove to me that it's a
chinchilla
uh the photo you sent didn't it didn't
work
which one did you click no it just took
me to the search result page
okay never mind
well dan what are your plans with the uh
giant rodent
are you going to put it in your living
room
are you going to be um putting it in
your bedroom perhaps at your front door
yeah because we
we don't have the room for this in the
office
no we dan's going to have to
do something i think
yeah what's your plans with this
uh this will not be coming home with me
i think that's right dana always gets
the
gift
yeah that's kind of true and last year i
got that [ __ ] the curse the first
carriage yeah left in my [ __ ]
basement yeah and then yeah
those teeth are pretty cursed
i mean if i had room for it maybe i'd
take it i don't know how does it smell
will you smell
your cats will love it damn
that's true
they might actually
okay fantastic it doesn't really smell
like anything so i had to uh hire a
moving guy to get this here
and
he pulled up with the truck
and he just started like
cackling with laughter and he goes
i've never seen anything like this in my
life
working in this business
and the whole time he was strapping it
he's like i can't go on the freeway
because this is gonna fly right off the
truck bed
and he was just
he was so happy he was like this is the
weirdest thing i've ever moved
well that is the spirit of craig's miss
just joy everywhere
i just noticed the eyes are bloodshot
the eyes are below bloodshot
little rabbit chinchilla
why is the nose so specific
yeah why is the it's like a rudolph
chinchilla nose
all right well the camera on this oh no
it works um anyway that's it a
yeah that's uh that's everything that's
amazing well thank you so much
for this
i guess thank you ian and sam
merry craigslist well done
enjoy the rap my friend
what's up with that case dude
you guys what's up with the cake what's
up with the case you want to continue
the conversation zack if i'm allowed
yeah yeah go for it
hold on let me just copy my
my tomato emojis
yeah get that queued up now zach let me
ask what is it you're looking to find
out about the case i just who owned it
what's what's the vibe what
what what's the voodoo on it can you
give him as much information as you can
zack or ian
tell him everything the vibe what's the
vibe vibe check
i don't know the guy kind of had like um
uh
[Music]
let me let me let me get a reference
he kind of looked like uh lurch
lurch
yeah
lurch from adam's family yeah
okay i'll pull up a photo of lurch know
him well
so is that
is that good or bad
i mean i do enjoy the adams family what
well then great but good energy lurch is
a fictional character what
this is lurch for reference
um
the whole back story there like this
yeah
shout out was he wearing was he wearing
a tuff
uh bolo tie
sports coat vibe
any other questions you have from zach
can i oh
what was the listing
of the item do we have the listing i'd
like to review that as well uh let me
look i can i can that would be
interesting hold on
exactly
zach you should be aware people are
throwing tomatoes bring it on
not not to dissuade you yeah
we gotta find this exactly
i desperately need a bathroom break how
long we've been going dan we i just hit
the refresh thing so give me two hours
20 minutes there you go okay
i need a rabbit man to bless it
is is she not enough do you also need a
rabbi i'd like both both would be good
okay
yeah
i just wanna know this thing that's all
i wanna know
and then i'll shut up
all right so we're waiting for the
listing
zach are you experiencing like
existential like dread at this moment or
something a little bit yeah okay
pretty [ __ ] are you regretting that you
chewed on the steak even though you
didn't no it was quite tasty to be
honest okay plus me and abe had a very
nice bond yeah really anything happened
we're going you guys had a strong moment
we had a very intimate moment
okay so this is the posting
rare
hard cases suitcase weird horror
sold is that that's that's me that's you
you bought it yeah okay
good condition
good condition please see all picks and
ask any questions oh they're not things
that's extremely mundane that's fine
yeah is that acceptable to you beyond i
just want to can we see the other photos
though
no because this is just a screenshot
it's just pictures of the suitcase all
right then that thing's sick all right
so we're safe we're good thank you thank
you
thank you yeah thank god thank you
you were afraid that it was a strange
individual selling it right like
you know harvested organs that type of
[ __ ]
i don't think you can sell that on
craigslist well this is offer of this
different ball game
um
oh yeah the different terms and
conditions over there yeah yeah
but thank you anne thank you sam i do
appreciate it all right well
congratulations it's not cursed
we can still have uh the ghost hunter
come and cleanse it okay
up next we've got our final segment of
the day right do we have anything else
uh
i think
yeah it can be our last thing
you're talking about the predictions
well is there any other holiday stuff
yeah i was going to do the predictions
any holiday stuff no i don't think so no
other holiday stuff
all right let's do the you want to se i
got to go peter someone want to set up
this bit and i'll be right back sure
okay yeah
i'll be right back
okay
uh do we have any cool uh like gambling
casino vibes there
yeah some lounge music bro lounge
okay
so uh
what we're going to be doing everyone is
we're going to be playing uh
some
gambling predictions for 2022 so we've
written a couple predictions down
and we've all been given chips
uh every person here has 10 ships
and
we're all going to be making predictions
for the year and if you guys have
predictions too you can post them in the
chat maybe we'll pull some from there if
they're good
so things like um
i have an easy one written down
something like i think uh
uh
the movie avatar two is gonna be a bomb
flop
and then i'll be like i'm gonna put one
chip and if someone thinks it's gonna be
a success they will bet one chip
[Music]
and we will uh
see who has the most chips at the end of
the year if that makes sense
that makes perfect sense to me
i'll actually i would just say that that
movie isn't coming out this year um
that's a good one because i don't think
it actually exists
love are you uh having fun with pete
no
no
oh look at that he's
he's the new love dog
me and my boy petey
exciting
okay so is this uh
should i put this up this graphic
are you doing it from back there ian
okay just saying
oh wow
okay
i see wow we've like gamified this whole
thing yeah so this will kind of be an
uh throughout the year
so and we can like add to it later right
like yeah think of another one and be
like all right all right so everybody's
gotta keep track of their chimps man
yeah do not lose that these are valuable
now what is the
um what is the prize like when somebody
wins what do they get
uh we'll have to determine uh is it just
a title thing
it could be the prophet thinking like
like a
blinged out sort of crystal ball or
something
yeah
for the office clear voyage
love that
i got to do the love that thing since uh
olivia's in here yeah
we're missing that here cut to me olivia
if you're watching this is for you i
love that
we've been staying around the office uh
you can't stop saying it she's she just
love that i love that and uh it's so
it's so beautiful
it is very beautiful it's so beautiful
it's very beautiful sam and i have this
like weird way of
talking
that kind of caught on we go it's very
beautiful or something or something we
[Laughter]
i just saw a decent one cap cap gets a
divorce
in the chat we should keep an eye on the
chat and grab that name yeah okay i'm
gonna start dropping in some good ones
in here
calf calf gets a divorce good one
too much wine sorry
keep them coming people let's see
uh the queen dies i think we already
have that on our list um
always take hydration seriously please
please take care of everyone oh there's
one in the super chat one of the crew
members will get engaged
oh interesting you know i i
thought about that one
[Music]
i'm gonna bet that just put pressure on
you guys
get wrecked
jordan peterson becomes a feminist i'm
not taking that bet
no sorry
uh abe loses his boxing match okay so
uh the boxing thing is
um
on the list
however really decided it would not be
fair for him to bet on that that would
be like an unfair especially him losing
because then he could just take a fall
um
whereas it's a little bit harder for you
to rig winning i suppose right you can
bet on yourself i guess
i think he's gonna win someone else can
take his bet too
right
zach will get cursed
by the end of this year
[Laughter]
uh love moves to l.a
it's interesting oh [ __ ]
i mean easier said than done moving from
another country
uh olivia will date uh pete davidson
jfk junior comes back
i found mashed potatoes
try the flip
uh
hassan and ethan fight for real where
are you reading this from other chat a
lot of people we hear predictions so we
explain the predictions and yeah i mean
if there's good ones we we can we can
bet on ones that were suggested by the
chat so so
as a bet
gets a divorce this year
that's interesting that's a complex idea
because he's already getting
bold right that and that's kind of the
thing isn't it is
maybe he's happy with the sort of
arrangement that he has right now so
that's a pretty good bet though
they're not divorced right now
not as far as we can i don't believe
they're divorced happily married
[Laughter]
right
by the way no
i didn't explain yet but ryan cavanaugh
we said that
hit the web the case against the website
was dropped
and he refiled it
he's back he's back
again did take down does ryan kavanaugh
look like harvey weinstein
so
all right
i want back to one down three to go
so let's play okay okay so we have a
little intro right uh yeah to kind of
kick us off
we don't have it ready okay we don't
have a little intro pretend like i never
said that people
never happened
well uh we can start running through a
couple of them here
so
first up uh ethan suggested uh
a new coveted variant
is gonna come out and now do you mean
like a
like a huge one like like something on a
little bit
i mean i mean it's a big one i'm not
taking that bed i mean of course that's
gonna happen
wait so if you think what do you want to
happen
yeah we'll be betting on it somebody has
to somebody no no no somebody has to be
willing to take take you on somebody has
to take the bet
someone has to think that you're you
know there won't be one i think we're
good i think omicron is the end i'll
take that bet
i think there won't be any more i think
we're going to be out of the woods i'll
take that back to you
all right who wants to bet so how much
you want to put up i mean obviously i
feel like the odds are against me
but i feel like this is the one job last
we're going to keep it strong humanity
wins
my mom told me that she read something
that said that
they they think um omicron is the last
one
just like it was written by me
i wrote that
so you're saying there won't be omega
no more omegas no more no pie no uh
whatever
letters
this is the last wave and we're and
we're good we're back to normal life in
a few months i'd say
now
back to normal life that can mean a
number of things no big ass [ __ ]
variant coming like omicron did to to
crush our dreams yeah i'll take you up
at for sure okay how much are you
willing to bet
you have 10 tokens so you got to fix
strategies put two on it i'll
i'll take that but do i get odds because
i feel like i you should give me like
three to two odds no
just two to two
it's gonna get so complicated okay
you're right okay so so someone marked
that down dan's taking me up anyone else
want to take anybody else want that okay
yeah definitely
wow everybody wants action on this
this could be a little oh wait so this
could be really lucrative or really
horrible for me yeah yes
i'm down i think this is going to be a
windfall for me so we put up two chips
right
yeah okay okay so is that who's not
taking up that bet
is anybody not
not taking them you know what no she's
taking it taking it
okay it sounds like it's ethan versus
everyone
so is someone writing this down so we
are all saying there's gonna be another
one
yeah yeah but that means i have to pay
all y'all out if i'm wrong you don't
even have too many chips we'll all get
two i only have does that mean i can't
bet on anything else no no the house
will cover it we'll figure it out all
right so i got two on that okay
everybody put your chips in two okay
exciting i think i'm right
okay next one uh
keemstar gets exposed by an x is another
ethan suggestion
by his high school girlfriend
um
i mean i feel like that's
pretty likely to happen yeah with the
way he's been acting i mean he's already
had two
very young girlfriends that
in just the last time it's almost
inevitable right yeah these young girls
are so immature too
right one of them's gonna want a lot of
hungry probably as well
i mean
why would you even consider touching
keemstar unless you were getting
something out of it right mm-hmm
absolutely
so does anybody want to bet that he's
not getting exposed this year so does
anyone want to bet that keems well first
does anyone want to bet that keemstar is
going to get exposed by an x
this year i agree that that's probably
going to happen
so you want to put money down on that
but is anybody thinking it's not going
to happen yeah that's the thing i don't
think anybody's going to be willing to
take you on the bed i think that's a
pretty high probability i'm so [ __ ]
angry i'm so [ __ ] happy
i get someone said keem posting about me
on christmas again
definitely gonna happen well we're on a
two-year streak right now right
yep
um
that one might interfere if we like wait
till the end of the year to check back
like if we do this us betting on it
may affect but i feel like it's like
those uh
time traveling situations where like no
matter what happens is going to find
himself tweeting about you on christmas
day
we can all try to interfere but all
right let's skip the keemstar ones yeah
it sounds like nobody's everybody's
believing that's gonna happen yeah yeah
uh okay uh here was another one uh joe
rogan gets dropped by spotify
interesting
i'm in i'm not willing to bet that i'm
going to say
yeah i'm going to say no i don't think
they'll drop spotify is going to drop
them maybe how much you want to put down
for that
two
i'll take you on that gets my dick hard
i'll take action on that
i think it's too lucrative for them i
don't think they're gonna lose their ass
if they fire if they do something yeah
i'll take action on that
uh so ethan and dan are taking that
loves taking action on that so we're all
saying no that he's not going to except
for you is there a time period or just
this by the end of this whole year
at some point this year will spotify
drop joe rogan
i'll take that
uh okay um the next one the queen dies
she's already dead wait she's still
alive
she is she's theoretically still alive
but i think that she
is like she's still alive
oh her husband died
right yes
i mean but i'm saying i think that she
did die like in the last couple of
cyborg or some [ __ ] and they have i
think she hasn't been seen in public and
she hasn't yeah she's like in hiding
right now
okay so who's willing to bet that she
lives another year i will
you're putting money on that ian uh me
no that's love you about money on that
oh yeah how much you know they're
juicing themselves up with uh fierce
blood or something they're gonna survive
for hundreds of years how old is she now
doing
200 billion
[Music]
how old are you actually i'm looking
95 years old jesus
she couldn't know that you could live
another year
yeah
for sure i could see her lasting another
year
although studies say that
old couples the
surviving spouse is likely to die within
a year of the other one that's true so
she could have another year alive
so okay
um
love you're betting she's going to live
yes
i'll take that bet how much
do you want to go all in
all in no no don't we need to get more
bad betting on someone's death that's
funny
bad vibes okay you want to take me off
wow i think she's going to die though
i'll take you on okay cool yeah
okay good yeah yeah two yeah for sure
all right let's go
all right so that's that's me versus
love nobody's else in on this nope it's
very clear of the death of the uh
deadpool i was going to go in until
ethan said that and now i'm not going to
he's right
99.9 of cases i agree but it's the queen
yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] gonna die [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah
here was a uh zach suggestion uh he said
i will get a rolex
i mean that ain't happening
you can't bet on this first of all zach
because it's completely within your
control you could
theoretically buy
a rolex so it would have to be oh he can
bet on it he can bet on it what really
he ain't doing it he ain't buying i'm
saying no not happening do i have to
purchase it is that better no i don't
think it matters
okay will you have a ten thousand dollar
rolex by the end of this year i'm gonna
say
not happening this year all right i'll
you know what and i'm gonna be the let's
face it if anyone's gonna get your rolex
it's gonna be me
you know what
i believe in my boy oh thanks a.b you
think it's gonna happen
yeah
how much you wanna bet
one chip
done i take that one heart one should i
raise you
i'm all in just like love i'm all in on
this one one chip i got you
okay no rolex this year okay i
appreciate you ap so what's the win baby
zach and ab are putting in one chip that
zach will get a rolex who wants to bet
that he won't i'm betting he will not
zach or yeah ethan's betting that he
won't got it okay
i'm staying out of this one i feel like
this is this one's too easy to to poison
the well with yeah it's all within our
control yeah all right
uh okay another one zach suggested he
said
i have to explain this one
i i asked him do you have any
predictions for the year and he said
this without skipping a b he goes
richard simmons will make a comeback
you're familiar with who he is right of
course okay
so he has not been in the public eye
since like 2016.
and there's all these theories about him
that his housekeeper is holding him
hostage and
what yeah he hasn't been in the public
eye however he did an interview on the
today show and i believe it was 2016.
73 dude ain't no comeback hold on
he
the public wants him the public needs
him can you imagine richard simmons on
[ __ ] tick tock sweat to the oldies oh
that could be a thing actually how hyped
i would say actually i could see that
richard simmons on tick tock would be
pretty fire i mean come on dude he he
needs to have a comeback richard if
you're out there i believe in you
that's beautiful you can come back so
what's your theory though he's being
held hostage by his housekeeper there
was a podcast that came out called in
search of richard simmons
and they went to go find him and see
what's up with him and
he's just been in his house
did they find him or no no they had an
article that said that lapd did a
wellness check on him and he's fine and
he's fine yeah dude
free richard free richard thompson
richard
dude i mean they they harassed this poor
guy to the point where the police had to
check up on well it wasn't really a
harassment thing it was more of like is
he okay who was worried about him he's
mined in his own business a lot of
people were because he just dropped off
the face of the earth is that a fair
wellness check what do you think or is
that i don't know the guy
he is like you're not familiar with
richard simmons yeah he was on howard
stern a lot he's the guy goes gary gary
where are you gary
i guess he's funny flamboyant so i i
think he would shine on tick tock i
think he would be amazing and this man i
feel is gonna come back this year i have
a gut feeling okay
it's a curveball but i'll take that bet
i'll bet you on that two chips sure okay
it's on
i'm in okay
free richard actually lock richard up i
want to win three richard dogs
i'll put in two as well i don't think
richard's coming back right shirt is not
dude richard's done yeah as much as i
want to buy a richard simmons chia pet
i was gonna be in i don't know if i'm
willing to do i mean i only have four
chips left
richard simmons [ __ ] you know
do you think he's he's not gonna come
back i don't think he's coming back okay
i think i think the world has gotten
all the richard simmons that it's gonna
never this man is an icon he's a legend
i don't disagree with you but i think
this is it i think we've gotten our
quota he's richard on tick tock now is
that
you say come back yeah is that what you
imagine is him on tick tock any type of
social media we know yeah any type of
social media post anything just
something in the public eye yeah just
say hey i'm okay yeah that's right okay
yeah get this outfit he's a legend i'll
take that bet for one but i'm not taking
it for two all right fine i'll downgrade
to one i'm taking my one back then okay
fine okay deal all right i'm taking the
bet for one so zach zach's saying he's
making come back me ethan
and ian yeah
we're all saying no
no oh and can't and me and not happy
that's fine dude i support that is not
him
either's with you zach you're with me
eli
oh i mean i was just not gonna bet she's
just cheating oh okay he's staying out
of the room in a sense you are free
richard how many
one
uh okay here's another one uh
kavanaugh
files at least one more lawsuit against
ethan
[Laughter]
that's a guarantee you guys think he'll
hit that fifth
for sure that magical fifth yeah
i mean does an appeal count i guess not
that's that's part of the same case
right no appeal doesn't count oh
well
it would have to be a whole new action i
think right you haven't cause he's
pretty much already sued me for
everything what everyone else is
defamation tortious interference
copyright infringement what else can you
sue someone for well he's about totally
harmed but i mean we're not doing that
so an inappropriate relationship by the
14 year old natalie portman
you have one of the channels now so it's
possible you do make a good point i
would in my mind it was like guaranteed
he's already sued me for everything you
can sue another individual for what
would it even be like what what others
what other
civil you know
civil suit can he bring against me i
mean i didn't know about torture's
interference yeah he invented yeah
that's true there might be something i
don't know
he is deeply litigious he might know all
kinds of angles we could never even
dream of i feel like it would have
happened already
he's all kind of already got everything
he could get out there i mean listen you
could take the bet
i'm not gonna bet on it
you don't want to manifest that
yeah i felt like i would definitely take
it but now you you have a really good
point it's like what
what is he gonna he could sue love
that's a good point that's a good point
yeah i would count that as another
lawsuit that's true he could also sue
wikipedia mods
throats get sued i will defend the ropes
forever bro
gross if you're watching
i got you're back homie i think maybe
it's like a general
another lawsuit in this whole
saga a related lawsuit maybe not me
necessarily it could be love it could be
throats it could be wikipedia itself and
to that i say a definite yes
okay how many chips that's more probable
one chip
i'll do two so what you're saying it's
gonna happen yeah well someone has to
take against you someone have to say
it's not gonna happen and who's
confident enough to say that
or we all agree i think everyone agrees
you know what i'll take the bet just for
this just for the for the sake of it
i'll take the bed i could take not bad
no more you want to do one ryan
cavanaugh's done he's done with the
lawsuits
i know i'm gonna regret just doesn't
sound right yeah
yeah that doesn't sound like this
party's just getting started well i'm in
on this though i say he's gonna yeah
i'll take the bet too dan and i think he
i think the lawsuits are over yeah i'll
bet i'm willing to throw one ship all
right let's do one okay so dan's gonna
take the bet so i'm taking the bet no
more lawsuits ryan cavanaugh has got
done anyone got access to that i got one
one chip okay
let's use my adv but i swear that jordan
peterson had us moving it's looking
around every time it cuts back to it oh
like the haunted house where they yeah
[Music]
where would we
okay
be
uh av wins his boxing match
okay well he's definitely boxing this
year
right
oh i can't do i can't bet on this part
ab it's okay he can um we'll pull up a
picture of us we can't we can't we can't
it's not public yet oh [ __ ] yeah oh
why isn't it public yet
uh because they're securing some details
so tell me about your opponent's
physicality okay i will say that uh he's
in great shape he's been working out
for over 10 years uh this is from what i
understand it could be wrong with some
details yeah noah
i've seen a photo he has uh i believe
he's involved with at least a few
channels but his main channel he runs by
himself is all about fitness
and muscles
are you afraid you're gonna get killed
uh no
you're not because if i die dan said
he's gonna avenge me like rocky iv not
actually killed but like beat up
uh no as long as i survive then
w
you think you have a chance to win
just because yeah i do because my coach
is really hardcore like really
yeah and he's taller than you too right
he's a little taller than me yeah so
he's more jacked more jacked more fit
more fit taller yeah is an athlete he's
an athlete
you're gonna die you're gonna get
murdered
i'll bet on a b winning me too i'm going
through it two chips you know what i got
the love of the food patrol seriously
i'm gonna absorb their energy like a
spirit bomb you guys are making me look
like an [ __ ] i'm just asking
questions
i got two chips he's gonna win no thank
you thank you can we can
we i guess
i would take the bet
if it was modified slightly to
maybe will will go the distance he won't
get knocked down i think he's got a good
shot at going the distance yeah oh i
like that i like that but i don't i love
uab but i i don't know if i'm confident
enough to to put money on listen
but i think that you i don't think that
you're going to get i'm not i'm not hurt
but i don't think you're going to get
knocked out yeah
w
i don't think so right well
you think abe is going to win
yes okay who else thinks abe is going to
win i'm going to go for a win eliza b
winning anyone else i'm in oh wow okay
so amy's losing so maybe someone had to
do it
i'm going to be cleaning up on these
guys though
i did find some motivation though
because like i don't you know what i'm
taking maybe losing too
baby's losing as soon as i said i found
motivation he's winning no i'm thinking
that he's losing wait i thought only one
person could bet that he's losing no no
okay four people on either side
somebody's
so it sounds like ethan and i are saying
abby's going to lose i'm sorry
i'm sorry av i've seen the guy he's uh
i'm not hurt but [ __ ] him
yeah but again i don't think you're
getting knocked out i mean either i
believe in you i think it's awesome
you're doing it
so prove me wrong i just want to say it
was like at first it was hard to like
find motivation because i don't really
know the guy you know i mean in terms of
like i wanted to hate him because i
thought it would help motivate me but
then a thought crossed my mind like a
week ago that keemstar is probably going
to be at that fight
and he's going to love to talk [ __ ] on
me losing right and i'm
i'm i'm i'm ready now interesting
i think you're going to lose
i don't think that's gonna
you should tell idubbbz that if
you ain't boxing if keemstar is allowed
in that stadium
that dumbass should not be anywhere near
that
can i just say like when i met idubbbz
because i met with him a few times he's
the nicest guy i was
i mean i didn't think he'd be mean or
anything but like
unnaturally unhumanly nice him and
anissa they're very sweet yeah yeah
they're great
agreed
is that all of it locked in locked in
sounds like that's locked in i only have
one ship left to bet
coming down to the wire here
[Music]
uh
we go the year with no uh
channel strikes
that ain't happening
well we got two last year
right but i don't think we ever had one
yeah all the years we did before that
right did we get one
when they
uh took down our stream with the alex
jones stuff remember that that wasn't a
strike that was just or maybe they
reversed it or i don't remember that was
the only other time that they got a
strike but they reversed it really fast
but yeah somehow we managed to
leap frog up to two i don't think i
don't think we'll get a strike this year
someone wants to take me i'll take that
bet yeah
i don't think we'll get a strike
[Music]
okay i only have one to bet though okay
so i take it
anyone else think we are not going to
get a strike
or are i said we're not
right and i'm saying we will at some
point in the next 12 months get a strike
on okay i'll take that up now let's
clarify right now what if it gets
reversed
is it still i think as long as the
strike occurs then you win okay yeah
is that it anyone else want to get in
okay really nobody else is interested in
protecting i can't make up my mind
[Music]
i don't want to put that energy on the
air
you don't want to manifest yeah
i think we'll be all right this year
[Music]
well theoretically you have control over
this bet exactly
but does it not really the last one was
a two-year-old video
right
yeah now that's an interest hmm
that's an interesting one it's like i
had no control over that yeah right
who would have predicted that one
[ __ ] dude
all right well uh okay let's move on
uh okay uh galaine maxwell gets uh
taken out
all in
i think she'll be fine
yeah i'm all in for that one so you
think she's gonna get unalive yep i
think she'll be fine i'll take that back
she's gonna get back dude
how much you want got on that three
that's what i only have two left that's
fine
i got two on jalen is going to survive
the year all right
nobody cares about her
elaine's gonna survive two on it cool
and i'm all in
[Music]
is she gonna survive i don't know if she
wouldn't have dropped it oh no if she
was gonna drop that it would have
happened already she's walking dead dude
well she only just this last week said
that she was gonna spill names
i don't care
okay i guess that's locked in just me
and you i love okay it seems like it
didn't i might be rooting for her health
i'm starting to um
feel like i need to move or something
you got back pain yeah i mean you can
always save we could save some for later
too do we have a lot left still i'm not
shipped so i'm out of chips as well
so maybe let's yeah we can we can do
some further betting later so we need to
wrap it up well just power maybe just
power through
uh jake paul maintains his perfect
streak
he's gonna lose this year for sure
[Music]
who cares
who [ __ ] cares
um
i mean there's nothing really like i
thought okay super relevant that we have
to do
okay all right so we'll call it yeah
let's call it all right well merry
christmas to everyone merry christmas oh
can you guys help us with titles you
guys want to pitch some titles to us
real fast ethan will lose weight there's
a good one anyone want to bet on that
that's sad if i had chips i would uh i
would take that back i will bet that you
are going to lose weight me too oh
i'm going to come back i'm going to gain
100 pounds this year
i think you'll lose weight
what are you betting on
i'm not betting on that
i think you'll lose weight i'll put a
chip on it all right well i don't have
any chips on it i'm because i don't have
any left
all right what do you guys got for
titles we need help
a little lost christmas episode the lost
christmas episode elo went into labor
mid episode oh my god that's a good
clickbait right there
let's see best title late christmas
stream
late christmas stream
i'm just reading off the chat's throwing
a bunch out so i'm uh make sure they
behave kim sharp is in his basement
the best christmas episode child's birth
for fried chicken
banned christmas episode
the christmas in january special the
early christmas episode that's kind of
funny maybe we should do it oh yeah
there's a massive rat in our office
is that really interesting clickbait you
think so the real reason why niko nico
avocado counts that's a [ __ ] yeah
that's good
[ __ ] christmas bruh yeah [ __ ] them let's
clickbait that [ __ ]
about christmas but we gotta at least
make some money back on this dude you're
right we gotta get our return on
investment oh yeah right
on that first class
yeah
[ __ ] dozer the real a [ __ ] dozer
wait we need a new thumbnail too
yeah i'm just writing it down the real
and all caps reason the real reason
avocado
avocado cancelled
what's like a more provocative word like
uh do you need the avocado in the title
that's his full name it's good for seo
because that's his channel i was just
thinking it makes it longer it is pretty
long but nicotto
canceled
did he bail did he uh bailed or bailed
flaked
cursed the episode
the real reason nicoto
canceled council seems to be the best
yeah
what do you guys like
gabe
gabriel
i'm still on the gabe nation
[Music]
eva's having twins again somebody says
nicka cotto avocado missed episode oh ed
sheeran i like that
just be like ed sheeran's our guest
pete davidson
david davidson and ed sheeran pete
davidson comes to our studio
oh pete davidson comes to our studio
it's pretty good clickbait
i like the avocado one though
pete davidson hides from kanye west in
our studio
kanye west
and pete davidson fist fight
in our studio
um nicotto scammed us someone said
no
that's pretty bad pretty good
pretty bad pretty good
scammed
so i guess just nicotta is suing us is
pretty good oh that's good because we
showed this video by the way i want to
say about nick that i was first of all
like i said he sent me a very sweet
email and he wasn't angry or at least he
didn't express any anger about me
reacting to his
patreon video so respect to him for that
too
i was expecting some meltdown over that
so nicotto is suing me is pretty good
clickbait because people are wondering
um my apology to nicocado
nicoto
yeah nicotto is the grinch
from rose
apparently on the nelk podcast according
to brianna trimmings they were talking
[ __ ] about the triller
there because apparently
they called them tricky because people
don't get paid from them
dana says they don't pay people
wow
this is dana white said that yeah on the
nail pod yeah he [ __ ] hates right
that's what i'm saying where's dana
white he needs to reach out we're allies
we're homies and he's he's joe rogan's
buddy though you know who throws it is
who's gross dana what do you think it's
daniel
i mean kevin has a lot of enemies you
know what i mean
like it would make sense to me that
someone else
in the world was funding some
revenge
campaign against him
not that i have any information about
that i don't know anything the end of
h3tv
well that's good somebody suggested that
in the chat that's good
because you're changing the name
that's very good
don't you guys think that nicotta will
get the bet the most views yeah
so the i like the real scant
that's what it's changed to you now the
real reason nicotine avocado flaked okay
good
nicot was a friend of me the real reason
nico got an avocado flaked
maybe for people that don't know the
flake to be like the real reason nico
avocado
screwed me the [ __ ] over all right we'll
do it off off of the screen yeah let's
get for you thank you guys thank you
everybody mary craig
craig smith
merry christmas great job ian lots to
look at all together in the new year
gila's going to give birth any moment we
may not have an episode on friday with
hilah
i know we're having oliver tree next
week
oh
right
should have been we should have been
hyping that all and also we're doing the
i can say
we're doing the steamies
but i don't know we're gonna do it on
friday or
uh it will be when it's gonna come out
yep but
yeah it might be in the can uh to be
posted later but whoa
but wait so the
when is all of our tree coming out we
should say
that will be uh the midweek episode next
week so wednesday for members thursday
for everybody else and um what the [ __ ]
yeah we're really not excited about it
it's gonna be a giant [ __ ] pain in
the ass he has a million you thought
[ __ ] nicotto was demanding this dude
like we've had multiple [ __ ] meetings
with this [ __ ] he he wants the world
and um
frankly
frankly
i'm hoping
that ethan cancels but that's that
decision i'm not canceling it's a good
she's gonna be a good show i think you
should flake on them by the way i wonder
that would be pretty epic just the flake
we got all kinds we bought we spent a
lot of money on this
interview already
[ __ ]
by the way i wanted to promote our teddy
fresh tick tock account we hired
a new girl macy who is awesome
she was making a bunch of really awesome
teddy fresh tick tocks we loved her
content so we hired her
to work on our with our social team our
marketing team and she's been making
basically a new tick tock every day on
the teddy fresh account let me give you
an example it has copyrighted oh yeah
music
maybe just for a sec no no okay no it
goes down
promoting the new collection
she's awesome
her content is great so
you guys are interested
our teddy fresh tic toc is finally
active
here's one she posted today she just
posted this in two hours ago she made a
freaking cake dude that matches
her top
which just came out
actually she she's especially doing a
good job because
uh because of kovid we're having
everyone almost almost everyone worked
from home
because of the variants going wild right
now so she's very restricted with what
she can do so
pretty cool
what do you think about that huh
also i see it i see a lot of people
asking what about leftovers
oh yeah we expect to talk about it i
think we explained before the break but
maybe
explain again
i'm confused too
wait you are kind of
i'm confused because what's going on
i don't know what are you saying said we
were back in two weeks but then but then
i was like i don't think so oh no we're
so we're going on a hiatus from
leftovers for a month or two basically
when the baby comes essentially what
happened is
with the baby coming we knew that
ethan's availability would be a lot less
because he's not going to be sleeping
for the next couple months so instead of
doing four episodes a week
uh we will only be doing three and for
the first couple weeks with the baby
that's maybe even a stretch but we're
that's the plan for now anyways so
until
what did we say um april
um
the episodes once the baby comes will be
a little bit more low-key they might
even be shorter
depending on how things go
and after that things will kind of shift
back to the normal schedule so we'll
we'll be going back to four episodes a
week uh i think you know
if some
something big happens we might we might
do emergency leftovers you know that's
not out of the question but
uh ethan just felt like it was way
like it's too much i gotta tell his son
because he ow
god i've got crazy arthritis or
something i pick up what you haven't
told hassan
no i did yeah i did
but he just said
on his stream that we're back in two
weeks which confused me
so we're back in wind february some [ __ ]
april [ __ ] your mom april how about that
jeez chill bro i'm having a baby i gotta
take some time off
all right i'll deal with this afterwards
thanks for watching everyone it's friday
our first friday of the week back we'll
be back on monday
as baby count 2002 it's like election
watch you know baby watch 2022 continues
it really could just happen at any point
now yes yes yes yes
you'll see the best
it from me podcast
over chair hp baby we podcast from now
you're watching h23
you're watching h233
you're watching h233
you're wet tonight to the
[Music]
shredder will start barking all
freighters acting sweet